I'm so glad the other two couldn't make it today. I'm Sean Hayes and I am the host of SmartLess. It's a show where we used to have two other hosts to have that. Can you believe the balls on this guy? I'm Sean Hayes. Hello. Hello. When they fucking plug my mic in, I'm gonna light this kid up.
我真庆幸另外两个今天来不了。我是肖恩·海斯，我是 SmartLess 的主持人。在这个节目里，我们以前还有另外两个主持人的。你敢相信这家伙这么大胆吗？我是肖恩·海斯。你好。你好。等他们把我的麦克风插上，我非得把这小子收拾一顿不可。
Oh. Sean. I was just... I was told that you guys couldn't make it. That's weird because I was just saying to my friend, what a great job you're doing on the intro. So, where does that leave us now? Just kind of like enjoy the show?
哦。肖恩。我只是……有人跟我说你们来不了。真奇怪，因为我刚才还在对我的朋友说，你在开场白里表现得真棒。那我们现在算怎么回事？就权当是享受节目？
Yeah, enjoy the show. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess.
对，享受节目。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。
SmartLess. SmartLess. Sean, Jason said to me the other night, he goes, I was facetiming him from his apartment, he goes, have you got it? Have you got it? Like, like as if it was like, have you gotten into my crackers? And I go into his cupboard and I open up and I had taken a photo of his fridge and all how bare it was.
SmartLess。SmartLess。肖恩，杰森前天跟我说，他通过 FaceTime 从公寓联系我，他说，你拿到了吗？你拿到了吗？就好像，就好像你在吃我的饼干一样？然后我走进他的橱柜，打开一看，我拍了张他冰箱的照片，里面空空如也。
And I sent it to him and Kimmel in Thoreau. And then I said, I said, yeah, let's take a look at these crackers. They are the most unappetizing looking crackers you've ever seen. Why? Because they're not edged in cheese or they're not edged in anything. It's cardboard with seeds. And then he says, I just come back from work and he goes, you eat after work? And I go, yeah, it's called dinner.
我把它发给了他和金梅尔、梭罗。然后我说，我说，好吧，来看看这些饼干吧。它们是你见过最没有食欲的饼干。为什么？因为它们的边缘没有奶酪，也没有任何东西。这就是加了种子的纸板。然后他说，我刚下班回来，他说，你下班后还吃东西？我说，对，这叫晚饭。
You know, a lot of people do it. They've been doing it for a minute. And I was having salad with grilled chicken. He's like, what are you doing? Because that just doesn't compute for him because he just, Jason, when's the last time you had like a burger or pizza or anything just horrible? I had a burger about three weeks ago and it was incredible. You guys should check into it.
你知道的，很多人都这么做。他们已经这么做很长时间了。我当时在吃沙拉配烤鸡。他就像是，你在干什么？因为这对他来说简直无法理解，因为他，杰森，你上次吃汉堡、披萨或者任何垃圾食品是什么时候？我大约三个星期前吃过汉堡，太棒了。你们应该去尝尝。
It's three weeks ago. Yeah. Ground beef. Three weeks ago. Remember's the date. Here. Oh, sorry. Remember's the whole thing.
那是三个星期前。对。碎牛肉。三个星期前。记住日期。给。哦，抱歉。记住整个事情。
Go ahead. What was on the calendar? It was on his calendar. The bun was soft, but with a crispy little edge to it. I went ahead and had a little ketchup, lettuce, tomato, cheese. Good for you. Jason's death row meal, they'd be like, well, what do you want? Most people, you know, I want a thing and a chicken and, you know, pasta with a huge
说吧。日历上有什么？这在他的日历上。面包很软，但边缘有点脆。我吃了一点番茄酱、生菜、西红柿、奶酪。真为你高兴。如果是杰森的死囚最后晚餐，他们会问，你想吃什么？大多数人，你知道的，我想要一份这个、一只鸡，还有，你知道的，一大盘
thing and a Sunday. And Jason's like, if I could have half a slice of a whole wheat pita, that'd be nice. And a half hour on the treadmill. Is it available? Yeah. Before he passes, before they wire him up to the chair. I've told you a million times there's a 600 pound man in here waiting to get out. I have to, I have to stay on the mouse wheel.
还有圣代。杰森就会说，如果能吃上半片全麦皮塔饼，那就太好了。然后在跑步机上跑半小时。有这道菜吗？对。在他死前，在他被绑上电椅之前。我跟你说过一百万次了，这里面有个六百磅的胖子等着出来。我必须，我必须一直踩着仓鼠轮。
Otherwise it's not going to end well. He's got me on this lemon water now too, which is, which has nothing in it but lemon and water. Yeah. Speaking of 600 pounds, we have a guy today who has 600 pounds of talent. Oh, 600 pounds of talent. Here we go. What a description.
否则结局不会太好。他现在还让我喝这种柠檬水，里面除了柠檬和水什么也没有。对。说到六百磅，我们今天请到了一位拥有六百磅才华的嘉宾。哦，六百磅的才华。我们开始吧。这什么形容词。
It is not a good segue. It's the name of his autobiography. Huge fan of this guy. I love that you have no idea who it is. I'm super excited that he's on the show. He's so nice to be here. I've been a fan of his and watching him for many, many, many years. I've never done a deep dive on this fella and doing so for today.
这可不是个好的过渡。这是他自传的名字。我是这家伙的超级粉丝。我很高兴你不知道他是谁。我超级高兴他能上这个节目。他能来这里太好了。我一直是他的粉丝，看了他很多很多年的节目。我从来没有深入了解过这家伙，为了今天的节目去了解了一下。
I had no idea we had so much in common. This is what we have in common. Okay. I'm from Chicago. He spent quite a while in Chicago. Specifically at second city. Not really in common, but go ahead. Yeah.
我不知道我们有这么多共同点。这就是我们的共同点。好吧。我来自芝加哥。他在芝加哥待了相当长一段时间。具体是在第二城喜剧剧团。其实不算共同点，但你继续。对。
No. Specifically at second city, which I also attended classes. He's Irish Catholic, youngest child of a massive litter. I'm also the youngest of a large Irish Catholic family. He is a big love of Lord of the Rings franchise and I think you guys know how I feel about all of that. Very. Yeah.
没有。具体是在第二城喜剧剧团，我也在那里上过课。他是爱尔兰天主教徒，是一个庞大家庭里最小的孩子。我也是一个大家庭里最小的爱尔兰天主教徒。他非常热爱《指环王》系列，我想你们知道我对这一切的看法。非常热爱。对。
A million times. We both grew up playing Dungeons and Dragons. We both have a connection to the daily show. What's so funny? Oh no. Oh no. What's so funny? Just the Dungeons and Dragons.
一百万次。我们俩从小都玩《龙与地下城》。我们俩都和《每日秀》有渊源。有什么好笑的？哦，不。哦，不。有什么好笑的？只是《龙与地下城》。
It's just so, so you guys both just crushed a lot of ass growing up. That's covered. Sean, Sean, how excited do you get when you hear the sound pew, pew, and pew? I just soiled myself. I think I get so excited. Okay. He's currently guys. He's currently in first place in the million year late night talk show race.
这只是，你们两个从小到大都泡过不少妞。这个跳过。肖恩，肖恩，当你听到“砰、砰、砰”的声音时，你有多兴奋？我差点尿裤子。我觉得我太兴奋了。好吧。他目前，伙计们。他在漫长的深夜脱口秀竞赛中目前排名第一。
My best friend in the whole world, Stephen Colbert, hang on, Stephen, what I love the pan down to tilt down, tilt down, there you go. There you go. That's professional. That's how you get number one. Yeah. That kind of technical expertise. Wow.
我在全世界最好的朋友，史蒂芬·科拜尔，等等，史蒂芬，我喜欢这个镜头下移，镜头下移，好了。好了。这才是专业的。这才是怎么拿到第一名的办法。对。这种专业的技术。哇。
You're not going to get that from Kimmel or Fallon. Listener. He's in a very, uh, uh, erudite, uh, uh, like library, uh, home den. It's kind of exactly how, by the way, another thing we have in common, Stephen. What is that? What is that? What is that? What's that?
你从金梅尔或法伦那里可看不到这个。听众朋友们。他正身处一个非常、呃、呃、博学多才的、呃、呃，像图书馆一样的家中书房。这简直就是，顺便说一句，我们和史蒂芬的另一个共同点。那是什么？那是什么？那是什么？什么？
I love it. I can't get enough of it. One volume, red book of West March edition of the Lord of the Rings. Wow. That's the Lord of the Rings. All of this behind me on this shelf is Tolkien commentary or the unfinished tales like, uh, you know, the fall of Gondolin or the children of Perrin. Over here is more Lord of the Rings commentary.
我太喜欢了。我百看不厌。单卷装的《西马奇红皮书》版《指环王》。哇。那是《指环王》。我身后书架上的这些全部都是托尔金的评论或者未完成的故事，比如，你知道的，冈多林的陷落或者胡林的孩子。这边是更多的《指环王》评论。
That's Smeagol. That's Golem right here. What's this? It's... Wait. Is that from the movie? Actual hero sword. He's holding up a sword from the movie.
那是史麦戈。那是咕噜。这是什么？这是……等等。那是电影里的吗？真正的英雄之剑。他举起了一把电影里的剑。
He's holding up the fucking swords that was used in the movies. Look at that thing. That's crazy. How did you get that? Okay. I don't care if you don't like Tolkien or the movies. You gotta like that. Incredible.
他举起了电影里用过的那把该死的剑。看那个东西。太疯狂了。你是怎么弄到的？好吧。我才不管你喜不喜欢托尔金或者电影。你一定会喜欢这个。太不可思议了。
You must have children all over the world. How do you stop getting laid? Baby, Steve. How do you stop getting laid? What is it? How are you not getting laid right now? I fight him off with this. Well, that's another one.
你在全世界一定有很多孩子。你怎么才能做到不再上床？宝贝，史蒂夫。你怎么才能做到不再上床？是什么？你现在怎么就没在上床呢？我用这个挡开他们。好吧，这是另一个。
And Doral, which was given to me by Viggo Mortensen. Another sword. Fucking Viggo himself gave this to me, dressed up as Eric Horne. No way. And it was the greatest sex I ever had. Wow. Viggo slept together. Wait a minute.
还有安杜瑞尔，是维果·莫腾森送给我的。又一把剑。维果本人把它送给我的，当时他打扮成埃里克·霍恩。不可能。那是我经历过的最棒的性爱。哇。维果睡在一起了。等等。
Is it? We're making news, guys. 100,000 percent. As I remember it. Did you buy those? Or were they given to you? They were given to me. This is actually one of the stings from the Lord of the Rings.
是吗？我们在制造新闻，伙计们。百分之十万。据我记忆。那是你买的？还是别人送你的？别人送我的。这其实是《指环王》里的刺针之一。
That's incredible. Wow. And I had to actually pry these both away from my kids because when my boys were young, they would fight each other with it. I'm like, I could pay for your college with this. Give me that. Listen, Steven, it's great to have you here on the show, man. Well, it's a pleasure.
太不可思议了。哇。我实际上不得不把这两把剑从我孩子手里抢过来，因为当我的男孩们还小的时候，他们会用这个互相打斗。我说，我可以靠这个付你们的大学学费。把它给我。听着，史蒂芬，很高兴你能来到这个节目，老兄。好吧，这是我的荣幸。
It's a pleasure to be here. Thank you for inviting me. Of course. I am such a big fan. I just brought up the bat, Steven. Is there some kind of like a mental adjustment you have to make in your brain to go from host to guest? Like is your instinct to take over an interview when you're the subject?
很高兴能来到这里。谢谢你邀请我。当然。我是你的超级粉丝。我刚刚提到了那把剑，史蒂芬。从主持人转变为嘉宾，你的大脑里是否必须做出某种心理调整？比如，当你成为被采访对象时，你的本能是接管采访吗？
Absolutely not. I'm fascinating and I am fascinated with me. I do almost every interview I do. I'm listening to the person going, I could answer this better. Sure. I could answer. Sure. I've read your bio.
绝对没有。我很迷人，而且我很着迷于我自己。我做的几乎每一次采访。我听着对方的话，心想，我能回答得更好。当然。我能回答。当然。我读过你的简介。
I did the pre. Yeah. I could answer. And you are shanking this. The urge to like just say, go, let's switch. I'm happy to do that. Do you like that? Do you like when a guest comes on and they kind of freestyles and goes and goes off script
我做过前期准备。是的。我能回答。而你把这搞砸了。那种冲动就像是说，走吧，我们换一下。我很乐意这么做。你喜欢这样吗？当一个嘉宾上来，然后有点自由发挥，不按剧本走时，你喜欢这样吗？
basically? Do you like that? Or do you like sticking to it? As long as they've got a story, that's all I care about. The only thing you don't want is for someone to come on and they say, just ask them about their first day on set, just asking them about first day on set. And then you say, so gosh, big, I mean, you're a young actor, you're there with all these like huge stars.
基本上？你喜欢这样吗？还是你喜欢按部就班？只要他们有故事，这就是我唯一关心的。你唯一不希望看到的是有人上来，然后他们说，只要问他们片场第一天的事就行了，只要问他们片场第一天的事。然后你说，哦天哪，太棒了，我是说，你是个年轻演员，你在那里和所有这些大明星在一起。
What was your first day on set like? And they go, it was great. And that's it. Yeah. Full start. And then you go like, fuck me. They like, they don't, if they say they're going to do one thing and they don't do it, that's when you just want to open a vein because you realize there's another 10 minutes with
你在片场的头一天是什么样的？他们说，挺好的。就这样。对。冷场。然后你就会想，操我。他们喜欢，如果他们说要做一件事却没做，那就是你想割脉的时候，因为你意识到还要和这个人呆上10分钟。
this person. The other version is if somebody is super, um, hey man, I just put it out there in their public life, you know, and then you have them on and say, hey, okay, put it out there. And they go, you know, people, people have different attitudes about, like they completely back away from whatever position or what their book says or, you know, some women are nice. Like, you know, whatever they go, because they, they see the audience, they see the audience and they'll say one thing on their stupid news show where there's no audience to yell at them, but they see my audience and they go, you know, everybody's got their opinions
另一种情况是，如果有人超级，呃，嘿，老兄，我只是在公共生活中把事情都摆在台面上，你知道的，然后你让他们上节目，说，嘿，好吧，把它摆在台面上。然后他们说，你知道的，人们，人们对……有不同的态度，就像他们完全退缩了，不管他们的立场是什么，或者他们的书上写的是什么，或者，你知道的，有些女人很好。就像，你知道的，不管他们说什么，因为他们，他们看到了观众，他们看到了观众，他们会在他们愚蠢的新闻节目上说一套，那里没有观众可以冲他们大喊大叫，但他们看到了我的观众，他们就会说，你知道的，每个人都有自己的观点
and they're like, that was, that's the worst. People who kind of play a character, they lose a little courage when they get in front of the audience. Right. And after them, will you, will you sort of like privately resent like privately, you're on my show. You should be, you should be entertaining. And will you kind of leave them hanging out to dry?
他们就像，那是，那是 糟糕透了。那些有点像在演角色的家伙，当他们站在观众面前时，他们就失去了一点勇气。对不对？而在那之后，你会，你会有点私下里怨恨，比如私下里，你在我的节目上。你应该，你应该表现得很有趣。而你会不会有点让他们晾在一边不管？
Will you throw them a lifeline? Well, I mean, I'm not there to like stick a knife in anybody. I don't like, even on the old gig, I didn't really wasn't there to do that. That was more of a, that was more of a ledger environment over in your show, Stephen. I mean, when you're there, when you're there, the general feeling from the staff is fuck him up. Fuck this guy up. No, I get it.
你会给他们一根救命稻草吗？好吧，我的意思是，我不是去给任何人捅刀子的。我才不，即使在以前的节目里，我也真的不是去干那个的。那更像是一个，那更像是一个账本环境，在你的节目里，史蒂芬。我的意思是，当你在那里时，当你在那里时，来自工作团队的普遍感觉就是——搞死他。搞死这家伙。不，我懂。
Fuck him up. And I like it. And they're like, before I go on stage, you're like, you know, you come back with his liver on a stick and you fucking don't come back at all because we are hurt by his presence in this building. Sure. You know why. Sure.
搞死他。我喜欢这样。他们就像，在我上台之前，你会说，你知道的，你带着他的肝脏回来，要用一根棍子穿着，你他妈的干脆别回来了，因为他的存在让我们在这个建筑里受到了伤害。当然。你知道为什么。当然。
I do know why. And then I go, I promise you, I will make him suffer. Though I'll tell you, someone who actually is actually, I have a pleasant hostility with is, that's Jason Bateman, because I've interviewed you a couple of times and I actually enjoy, there's a pleasant hostility with you as a guest. And I mean, pleasant. What does that mean? Don't you feel like there's a pleasant hostility?
我确实知道为什么。然后我说，我向你们保证，我会让他痛苦的。不过我要告诉你，有一个人，其实，我和他有一种愉快的敌意，那就是杰森·贝特曼，因为我采访过你几次，我其实很享受，作为嘉宾，你身上有一种愉快的敌意。我是说愉快的。这是什么意思？难道你不觉得有一种愉快的敌意吗？
Like we don't get along? Well, you're incredibly pleasant. Like you're such an enjoyable performer. There comes a butt. But there is. Nope, there it is. No, and. No, you said butt.
就像我们合不来？嗯，你令人难以置信的愉快。就像你是一个如此令人愉快的表演者。这里夹杂着一个“但是”。但是确实有。不，这不就来了。不，还有。不，你说了“但是”。
And there is. Good for you. Okay. Good for you. All right. But there is. Okay. But there is.
而且确实有。真为你高兴。好吧。真为你高兴。好吧。但是确实有。好吧。但是确实有。
Dot, dot, dot. There's a little charming nature. There's something about you that's a little hostile as a guest. It's anger. And I can't imagine. Motherfucker. Hang on a second. I can't imagine.
点，点，点。有一种迷人的特质。你身上有些东西作为嘉宾来说有点敌意。那是愤怒。我无法想象。混蛋。等一下。我无法想象。
I'm the only host who feels this way. We're friends. I might be the only one to tell you. I look forward to it. I love a guest who's a little hostile. Let me just say this for Jason really quickly, because you don't know this, Stephen. But one of the last times that Jason was on your show, he might have been a little hostile because he was going through something.
我是唯一一个有这种感觉的主持人。我们是朋友。我可能是唯一一个告诉你的人。我很期待。我喜欢有点敌意的嘉宾。我只想为杰森快速说一句，因为你不知道这个，史蒂芬。但杰森上一次上你的节目时，他可能有点敌意，因为他当时正经历一些事情。
Yeah. Yeah. Let me explain my hostility the last time I was on your show. You know about this? I don't think he does know. I actually don't know. I don't remember anything about the interviews, just that there was a sense, perhaps it's defensiveness and the hostility is as a rose's thorns.
对。对。让我解释一下我上次上你节目时的敌意。你知道这个吗？我想他并不知道。我其实不知道。我不记得关于采访的任何事情，只记得有一种感觉，也许那是防御心理，这种敌意就像玫瑰的刺。
Still beautiful, but defending one side. Let me say this. Let me say this. Jason and I were going to do this press thing and we were meeting at JFK. He was going to do your show and he shows up JFK late and he's a sweaty mess and he said, how did Colbert go? And he's like, Jesus fucking Christ. Right Jason?
依然美丽，但保护着一面。让我这么说。让我这么说。杰森和我当时要去参加一个新闻活动，我们在肯尼迪机场碰面。他要上你的节目，结果他迟到了，汗流浃背，他说，科拜尔的节目怎么样？然后他说，耶稣基督。对吧，杰森？
Is that the setup? Yeah. Hey, you're great. All right. So here's, first of all, Stephen. Do you want me to tell the story? No. I got it.
这就是背景故事吗？对。嘿，你太棒了。好吧，所以首先，史蒂芬。你想让我讲这个故事吗？不。我知道了。
Is this a true story? This is a true story. Am I about to hear a true story? Yes. Yeah. It's a true story. Now I will first say in my defense, I have a British mother who was very sarcastic and dry and so my sense of humor tends to be a little like that can come across as hot.
这是个真实的故事吗？这是个真实的故事。我是不是要听到一个真实的故事了？对。对。这是一个真实的故事。现在我首先要为自己辩护，我有一个英国母亲，她非常讽刺和刻薄，所以我的幽默感往往有点像那样，这可能会显得很有攻击性。
Okay. I apologize. You also have a lot of anger just below the surface. And I've got some anger below the surface. So here's the story, Stephen. And I will say, I will apologize to Mr. Jimmy Kimmel right now because I told him about this and he said, oh, you got to say that for the next time you're on. So screw you, Jimmy.
好的。我道歉。你内心深处也有很多愤怒。我内心深处也有一些愤怒。所以故事是这样的，史蒂芬。我要说的是，我要向吉米·金梅尔先生道个歉，因为我之前跟他讲过这个，他说，哦，你得把这个留到下次上节目时说。所以去你的，吉米。
I'm going to tell it to Stephen because Stephen owns it because it was on his show. So here's what happened. I come to do your show. I'm in the dressing room there, which by the way has no bathrooms. At least the dressing room I got. The dressing room I got. That is cool. Then I didn't get the lead guest dressing room, whatever it was, there's no Johnny in
我要把它告诉史蒂芬，因为这是史蒂芬的地盘，因为这是在他的节目上发生的事。事情是这样的。我来上你的节目。我在那里的化妆室里，顺便说一句，那里没有洗手间。至少我分到的那个化妆室是这样。我分到的那个化妆室。太酷了。当时我没有分到头号嘉宾的化妆室，不管怎样，里面没有马桶。
there. So here I am. They put you in the pit. They put me in the pit. So I'm in the pit and my little suits in there, my little outfit, my little talk show suits in there and everyone gets out of the dressing room. So I can change into my suit and I put it on and, you know, my wife likes me wearing stuff.
所以我就在那儿。他们把你塞进坑里。他们把我塞进坑里。所以我呆在坑里，我的小西装在那里，我的小行头，我的小脱口秀西装在那里，所有人都离开化妆室。这样我就可以换上西装，我把它穿上，你知道的，我太太喜欢我穿这些东西。
It's a little tight and I don't like it, but I guess I lost the battle on this one. So I put it on. It's a little bit tight. You know, it could be less tight if I just let a little of this gas out. I just came from dinner and things have built up a little bit and I feel like if I could just let this one bubble out, things would really work out for me. Again, let me remind the audience, true story, true story. All of this is completely true.
稍微有点紧，我不太喜欢，但我猜我在这一点上妥协了。所以我把它穿上。稍微有点紧。你知道的，如果我能把这点屁放出来，它就不会那么紧了。我刚吃完晚饭，体内积聚了一些气体，我觉得如果我能把这个泡泡放出来，事情对我来说就会顺利得多。再次提醒观众，真实故事，真实故事。所有这些完全都是真的。
Keep going. How nice is this suit? How nice is this suit? Armani. It's, please. What did you say to me? What is it? 1988?
继续。这套西装多好看？这套西装多好看？阿玛尼。拜托。你刚才对我说什么？是什么？1988年？
No, and it's not Hugo Boss either. They make lovely things. Something I can't even pronounce probably. Pierre Cardin. Pierre Cardin. That's it. Pierre Cardin. So the suits on or at least the pants are on such that I know I need to try to make a
不对，它也不是雨果博斯。他们做得很可爱。有些我甚至可能读不出名字的牌子。皮尔·卡丹。皮尔·卡丹。就是它。皮尔·卡丹。所以西装穿上了，或者说裤子穿上了，以至于我知道我需要在这里尽量腾出
little bit more room here. And so I released a valve a little bit. Out comes less, well, it's more than air. Less than solid. Now, what are we to air time at this point? What are we to air time? We're four minutes from, you're well done with the monologue. You're probably in commercial break and it's time to walk.
更多空间。所以我稍微打开了一个阀门。排出来的东西，嗯，与其说是空气，不如说是介于固体和气体之间。现在，我们离播出时间还有多久？我们离播出时间还有多久？我们离播出开场白还有四分钟，你的独白已经结束了。你可能正在经历商业广告插播，该上场了。
I haven't even got the makeup on yet because the makeup artist is waiting outside the door for me to get the suit on. So this is a problem and there's a knock on the door. She'd like to get the makeup started. Stage manager would like for us to be walking. So now I've got to get the pants off, get the underwear off and get rid of the underwear in the bathroom that doesn't exist there. So now I've got to bury the underwear in the trash can.
我甚至还没化好妆，因为化妆师在门外等着我把西装穿上。所以这是个问题，而且有人敲门。她想开始化妆了。舞台经理希望我们已经开始入场了。所以现在我得脱下裤子，脱下内衣，然后把内衣扔进那个并不存在的卫生间里。所以我现在必须把内衣埋在垃圾桶里。
I've got to top it with some Kleenex or something. Across the loaf. We usually have some bread and some cheese. No one's the wiser, no one can, and so any. So a couple of cancel the Croy. So suits still tight. Now I'm commando. I'm not feeling great about myself.
我必须在上面盖上一些纸巾之类的东西。盖在那个“面包”上。我们通常会备有一些面包和奶酪。神不知鬼不觉，没有人能，所以任何。所以取消克罗伊。所以西装还是紧。现在我是真空上阵（不穿内衣）。我感觉自己状态不太好。
I've forgotten all of my funny answers that I've worked on with the segment producer on the pre-interview. Now I'm sweating. I really need makeup. I've got David Cross in the dressing room next to me ready to pre-tape an episode and he wants to talk. And so I let him in. I tell him what's happened.
我已经忘光了在前期采访中和分段制作人一起准备的所有搞笑回答。现在我在流汗。我真的很需要化妆。我隔壁化妆室里有大卫·克罗斯，他准备预录一集节目，而且他想聊天。所以我让他进来了。我把发生的事告诉了他。
He thinks it's fantastic. He thinks I should lead with that. I elect not to. I get the makeup on, the powder, whatever. I make it out there and I sit down and we do our interview and that is probably the reason I was less than chatty. He just shat his pants, Steven, you know, you know, you want to know why I'm mad if I hadn't appeared on this podcast today.
他觉得这太棒了。他觉得我应该把这个作为开场白。我选择不这么做。我化了妆，打了粉，什么的。我走了出去，坐下来，我们做了采访，这大概就是我话比较少的原因。他刚刚拉裤子里了，史蒂芬，你知道，你知道为什么我很生气吗？如果我今天没有上这个播客。
You would have told that story on good for you. When it's my trash can, my show where that happened and you were going to tell that story on Kimmel. That's totally entitled to be a good point. You should be double the anger you are now. You owe me underwear. Absolutely owe me underwear because what size are we talking? Are you men's medium?
你就会在《早安秀》上讲这个故事了。而那是我的垃圾桶，我的节目，事情就发生在我的节目上，你本打算在金梅尔的节目上讲这个故事。完全有资格生气的。你现在应该加倍生气才对。你欠我内衣。绝对欠我内衣，因为我们在说多大的尺寸？你是男士中号吗？
Will. You're an M. Will. Boy. Small. He's a boy. Small. Now with his diet. All right.
威尔。你是M号。威尔。天哪。小号。他是个男孩。小号。现在加上他的饮食。好吧。
What kind do you like? Um, I like a boxer brief. Got it. Okay. Okay. Doesn't crawl up. Doesn't crawl up. Preferably a sort of a rubber saddle to it.
你喜欢哪种？嗯，我喜欢平角裤。明白了。好的。好的。不会往上卷。不会往上卷。最好带有一点橡胶边缘。
Hang on. There's a great question. He just asked you. Does it crawl up your leg? Does it crawl up your leg because it crawls up my leg? Uh, no, it doesn't because the fluid in the seat of it keeps it weighted, weighted down. It's like, uh, it's like a post it note against your ass.
等一下。有个好问题。他刚刚问你的。它会往你的腿上卷吗？它会往你的腿上卷吗，因为它会往我的腿上卷？呃，不，它不会，因为座位上的液体让它保持了重量，有分量。它就像，呃，它就像贴在你屁股上的便利贴。
You can imagine. We're like, he's how to go on, on Colbert. Not great, man. Not great. I took a shit in my pants and I fucking bury my underwear and I'm fucking, and now we got to get it in an all night flight. And he's like, for fuck's sake, I'm fucking, he was like very, you know what though, we can go down this rabbit hole.
你可以想象。就像，他在科拜尔节目上的表现如何？不太好，老兄。不太好。我在裤子里拉了一大堆屎，我他妈的把内衣埋了，我他妈的，现在我们得坐全夜航班。而他就像，该死的，我他妈的，他当时非常，你知道吗，我们可以深入探讨这个无底洞。
No pun intended up because I had a similar thing and in grade school, I was in eighth grade. I raised my hand. I had already crapped myself in my jeans. I was 12 years old. I raised my hand. I said, can I go to the bathroom? And she said, yes, I left.
双关语，因为我有过类似的经历，在小学时，我上八年级。我举起手来。我已经在牛仔裤里拉过屎了。我当时 12 岁。我举起手说，我可以去洗手间吗？她说，可以，我离开了。
I walk into the bathroom. I go into the stall. I take my underwear off. I throw it into the stall underneath next to me and then I hear all like the entire football team come into the bathroom and they go, whoa, dude, what the fuck, oh God. And they open the stall next to me and they're like, holy shit, oh my God, there's shitty underwear. Oh my God.
我走进洗手间。我走进隔间。我脱下内衣。我把它扔进旁边隔间的下面，然后我听到整个橄榄球队的队员都走进洗手间，他们说，哇，老兄，他妈的怎么回事，哦，天哪。他们打开我隔旁的隔间，说，卧槽，天哪，有屎内衣。天哪。
And I was shaking. I thought it was going to get literally the shit beat out of me again by these people. Oh, bless us. Don't we all have those stories? Will, well, you're up. Will, you probably never have, right? Batter up. No, I'm good.
我在发抖。我以为自己又要被这些人狠狠地揍一顿了。噢，天哪。难道我们都有这些故事吗？威尔，嗯，轮到你了。威尔，你大概从来没有过吧？轮到你击球了。不，我很好。
Batter up, Will. Yeah. I don't think I do. Come on. You've had, you have a history with alcohol. You must have wrecked plenty of shorts. My life wasn't fucking train spotting. Okay.
轮到你了，威尔。对。我想我没有。得了吧。你经历过，你有一段酗酒史。你肯定毁过不少短裤。我的人生可不是他妈的《猜火车》。好吧。
I wasn't like, you know, shitting beds, but I will say that I did, I did do a similar thing to you, Jason. I was spending the night with a lovely young lady at her apartment years ago, 25 plus years ago in New York city, just a tremendous date and getting to know you and woke up in the morning, had a little coffee at her apartment and, and then it got away from me. And I actually ended up opening the small window in her bathroom and throwing my underwear into the courtyard. So I threw it out of the building.
我可不是那种，你知道的，把床弄脏的人，但我得说，我确实，我确实做过和你类似的事，杰森。多年前，25年多前，在纽约市，我和一位可爱的年轻女士在她的公寓过夜，那真是一次绝妙的约会，我们互相了解，早上醒来，在她公寓喝了点咖啡，然后，然后我就有点控制不住了。我实际上最终打开了她浴室的小窗户，把内衣扔进了庭院。所以我把它扔出了大楼。
Stephen, we're going to complete the circle and we're going to go ahead and complete the circle. Yeah. Let's start the interview. Sure. I have one, I have one story like that involves Conan O'Brien, I have one, I have one story like that. People always say like, Hey, do you look at late night guys, I'll know each other.
史蒂芬，我们要画个圆满的句号，我们接下来就要画个圆满的句号。对。我们开始采访吧。当然。我有一个，我有一个这样的故事，和柯南·奥布莱恩有关，我有一个，我有一个这样的故事。人们总是说，嘿，你们看深夜秀的人，你们都认识吧。
Like I actually have friends with Conan, it's kind of a late onset friendship in our careers, but we were out, where were we? We were out in a deer valley in Utah and I was skiing out there with my family and Conan called me up and he said, could I ski with you guys? And I was like, ah, you know, and he said, please. I have no friend, I have no friends and I frighten my family and could I, and I said, I said, okay, I'll, yeah, all right. And so we met at the top of a silver strike.
就像我实际上和柯南是朋友，这是我们职业生涯中后期才开始的友谊，但我们当时在外面，我们在哪儿？我们在犹他州的鹿谷，我和家人在那里滑雪，柯南打电话给我，他说，我能和你们一起滑雪吗？我说，啊，你知道的，他说，求你了。我没有朋友，我吓坏了我的家人，我能，我说，我说，好吧，行，没问题。所以我们在银击滑雪道顶部碰面。
You guys know, we met at the top of silver strike and it's just, it's just me and him because my kids saw him and I said, I don't want to ski with him and, and there were, there were, you know, they're fans of Leno and they said, we don't want to ski with him and they, they, I made them take, I made them take a side because I saw like, if you want to be in show business, the most important thing in show business is to be in a camp. That's right. That's the most like talent, okay, or like dedication, but the most important thing is to pick a camp in Hollywood and never forgive anyone for anything they do.
你们知道的，我们在银击顶部碰面，只有我和他，因为我的孩子们看到了他，我说，我不想和他滑雪，而且，而且有，而且你知道的，他们是雷诺的粉丝，他们说，我们不想和他滑雪，而且，而且，我让他们做出选择，因为我看到，如果你想在娱乐圈混，娱乐圈最重要的事情就是选边站队。没错。这是最重要的，比如才华，好吧，或者像奉献精神，但最重要的是在好莱坞选择一个阵营，永远不要原谅任何人做的任何事。
Right, right. And, and they said, dad, we can't because we're Leno and I said, I understand. And I'm proud of you. I said, I'm proud of you. I'm proud of you. You're crying right now. It should be pointed out. You're crying telling this story about how proud you are.
对，对，而且，他们说，爸爸，我们不能，因为我们是雷诺派的，我说，我理解。我为你们感到骄傲。我说，我为你们感到骄傲。我为你们感到骄傲。你现在在哭。必须指出的是。你讲这个故事时哭了，因为你为自己感到骄傲。
And so they went off to do whoever with their mom and they went to go do that, get a big cookie size of their head. And so I get on the, I go on the lift with Conan and, and he is, you know, he loves the sound of his own voice. And so we're right on the left and I'm like, shh, we got the masks on. There's a chance for nobody to know who we are. You know what I mean? Cause we got, we got the helmet.
所以他们和他们的妈妈一起去找不知道谁了，他们去干那个去了，去买了一个有他们脑袋那么大的饼干。所以我上了，我和柯南一起上了缆车，而且，他，你知道的，他喜欢自己说话的声音。所以我们在缆车上，我说，嘘，我们戴着面具。有机会让别人认不出我们是谁。你知道我的意思吗？因为我们戴着，我们戴着头盔。
We got the, the, the goggles on. We got the mask. We can actually go out there and enjoy ourselves. He's like, I'm Conan O'Brien when we're in the lines and his helmet is the color of his hair. Like his helmet actually is the color of his hair. Okay. On the back, on the back of his, Andy Richter's face is stitched into the back of his jacket.
我们戴着护目镜。我们戴着口罩。我们其实可以出去享受一下。他却说，我是柯南·奥布莱恩，当我们在排队的时候，他的头盔颜色和他头发的颜色一样。就像他的头盔实际上和他头发的颜色一样。好吧。在背面，在背面，安迪·里查尔斯的脸被绣在他的夹克背面。
And I'm like, this is embarrassing. So we get on, we're on the, we're on the, we're on the, we're on the, we're on the left. It's on the left. We're not, cause it's not enclosed. It was just a big part of the story and we're, we're on the lift going up and he's talking, he's super kind of obsessed with Lou Diamond Phillips at this time. And he's, all he wants to talk about is an officer and a, and a movie or that thing on history channel that Lou Diamond Phillips used to watch, like Kelly's heroes or something.
我说，这太尴尬了。所以我们上了，我们在，我们在，我们在，我们在缆车上。在缆车上。我们没，因为那不是封闭式的。那是故事很大一部分，我们在，我们在缆车上往上走，他在说话，他当时超级迷恋路·戴蒙德·菲利普斯。而且，他只想谈论《军官与间谍》和一部电影，或者是历史频道上路·戴蒙德·菲利普斯以前看过的那个节目，比如《凯利的英雄》什么的。
And then he would interview someone saying, how was that tank battle? Was that accurate? And, and he's like, why the fuck does Lou Diamond Phillips like, I know he was in that movie with like Meg Ryan about like something about Denzel Washington and Tim, but why does he get to be the guy who interviewed officers and he like, he's like, he will not let it go. He's got, he's got. Sorry.
然后他会采访某个人说，那场坦克大战怎么样？准确吗？然后他就像，为什么他妈的路·戴蒙德·菲利普斯会喜欢，我知道他和梅格·瑞恩演过那部电影，关于什么的，丹泽尔·华盛顿和蒂姆，但为什么他能成为那个采访军官的人，他就像，他就是不肯罢休。他一直在。抱歉。
He's like, no, but you know, because he's, he's interviewing these people as if he's had military service when he, he always like, he does like a heel turn and like that. So Conan won't shut about Lou Diamond Phillips the entire time. And we're going over, and I know how you're going up and you'll be going others, you're going over ski runs. Yeah. And this is out West where like, it might take you 20 minutes to get to the top of the mountain.
他就像，不，但是你知道的，因为他在，他在采访这些人，就好像他服过兵役一样，当他，他总是像，他会来个急转弯，像那样。所以柯南一路上都在喋喋不休地谈论路·戴蒙德·菲利普斯。我们正在穿过，我知道你们是怎么上去的，你会经过其他人，你会穿过滑雪道。对。这是在西部，可能需要花20分钟才能到达山顶。
So you're looking at the people and you're judging the way they ski and everything. I'm going in, he, he sees like a little, one of these little like a conga line kind of like toddler ski class going, going by and he goes, I bet I could take a dump on those kids. And I said, I said, don't even joke about that. That's my children and their mother. Nice. That's not right.
所以你在看着人们，你在评判他们的滑雪方式等等。我正要进去，他，他看到一个小的，这些像一个小的一字长蛇阵一样的幼儿滑雪班路过，他说，我敢打赌我能在那些孩子身上拉一堆屎。我说，我说了，别开这种玩笑了。那是我的孩子们和他们的母亲。太棒了。这不对。
That's not, no, they weren't my kids, but there was like, you know, it was like whatever like they called the reindeer club or whatever it is, you know, and they all, they got the clips on the front of their ski. So they have to be in this pizza french fry pizza french fry pizza the entire time. Exactly right, which is how Conan skis by the way, pizza, pizza french fry, which isn't easy in his height. And so we're going over one of these runs. I don't know.
这不对，不，那不是我的孩子，但就像是，你知道的，就像他们称之为驯鹿俱乐部什么的，你知道的，他们都在滑雪板的前面夹着夹子。所以他们必须一直保持这种披萨薯条披萨薯条披萨的姿势。完全正确，顺便这也是柯南滑雪的方式，披萨，披萨薯条，以他的身高这可不容易。所以我们正在穿过其中一条滑雪道。我不知道。
It's like a homework bound or whatever. One of those things like that, you know, and Conan's like, I bet I, I bet I could do that. And I said, please don't try. And he said, too late. Sounds like you're daring me. And I'm like, you're in a full, you're in a full leg. You're in like a neck to ankle, like one piece jumpsuit.
就像是连接道之类的。类似那样的东西，你知道的，柯南说，我敢打赌我，我敢打赌我能做到。我说，请别尝试。他说，太迟了。听起来你是在挑衅我。我说，你穿着一整套。你穿着像从脖子到脚踝连体紧身衣。
How are you going to do this? And he goes, zip. He's got a flap in the back and he just scoots it out over the back is where hand to God, he yells Torah, Torah, Torah. That's his, that's his shit war cry. He yells Torah, Torah, Torah. Just like, have you ever seen like those movies where like a, like some sort of rescue squad has to put down a marker in the snow?
你打算怎么做？他说，刺啦。他后面有个拉链开口，他直接把那个屁股后面的拉链拉开，上帝作证，他大喊：虎！虎！虎！那是他的，那是他的屎之战吼。他大喊：虎！虎！虎！就像是，你有没有看过那种电影，某种救援队必须在雪地里放下记号？
So I helped you find you like, it's like, or it's like the flame retardant coming out of the planes. It's the same. It's the same. It's the same color as his hair. No way. 100%. A bright orange waist comes out of the corner.
这样我好找到你，就像是，或者像飞机喷洒的阻燃剂。是一样的。是一样的。颜色和他头发的颜色一样。不可能。百分之百。一道亮橙色的液体从小路里喷涌而出。
It's just like, it's like he lives just on Dorito dust and it just absolutely, he dropped it like when he dropped it, like one of those planes and just literally knocks these kids down. Lesson over. Absolutely knocks them down. Oh my God. And, and, and with just a high-pitched cackle and, and I'm like, are you okay? That is not.
这就像，就像他只靠多力多滋的碎屑为生，绝对是，他把它丢了下来，就像他从那些飞机上扔东西一样，直接把这些孩子们撞倒了。课程结束。绝对把他们撞倒了。天哪。而且，而且，伴随着一阵高亢的咯咯笑声，我心想，你没事吧？那可不行。
And again, the color again was like, remember when before you wore the wigs? Yes. Now it's all, when he still had hair before and he's all proud and I got to say, I'm, I'm impressed. Of course. I got to say a man, a man his age, that control. This is again, this is 100% true. 100% it happened.
而且再次强调，颜色又像是，还记得你戴假发之前吗？是的。现在全是，当他以前还有头发的时候，他很自豪，我得说，我，我很印象深刻。当然。我得说，一个，一个他这个年纪的人，那种控制力。再次强调，这百分之百是真的。百分之百发生了。
100% true. Yeah. He might remember this story differently than I do. And we've never talked about it. He's never talked about it since. He's never, from that moment, we never talked about it. We made a promise. He looked at me and his pride, it went from like pride to deep change.
百分之百是真的。对。他对这个故事的记忆可能和我不同。我们从来没谈过这件事。从那以后他再也没谈过这件事。从那一刻起，我们再也没谈过。我们做了一个承诺。他看着我，他的骄傲，从那种骄傲转变成了深深的恐惧。
He goes, I want you to swear that not only did you not see that, like you'll never say anything, but you'll never say we want skiing together. And I said, I won't ever say anything about us skiing together if you never say anything about it. Even that day? That second, from that second, didn't happen. Fuck around. We so appreciate the trust.
他说，我希望你发誓，不仅你没看到那个，你永远不会说任何话，而且你永远不会说我们一起去滑雪了。我说，只要你永远不说这件事，我也永远不会说我们一起滑雪的事。甚至连那天也不说？从那一秒起，那一秒开始，就没发生过。别瞎扯了。我们太感激这份信任了。
And one of the reasons was, is because we get to the top and obviously who's up there? Cops. Like they're like me. Sure. I thought you were going to say Lou Diamond Phillips. Jesus Christ. You raised what a ride. So let's begin the interview.
原因之一是，当我们到达山顶时，显然谁在那儿？警察。就像他们像我一样。当然。我还以为你要说是路·戴蒙德·菲利普斯呢。耶稣基督。真是一波三折。那么我们开始采访吧。
Sure. And I just want to say, I do want to add one more thing, if I can, before we start the interview. And none of this is recorded, right? No, no, no. This is all rehearsed. Yeah, this is all pre-reviewed. The one thing I want to say is that, again, as we remember things differently, it helped
当然。我只想说，在采访开始之前，我还想补充最后一件事。这些都没有被录音，对吧？不，不，不。这都是排练过的。对，这都是预先审核过的。我想说的一件事是，再次强调，既然我们对事情的记忆不同，它有助于
remember it differently than I do, if he ever talks about it again, is that the one thing I know happened is the Lou Diamond Phillips shit talk. That's the one thing I'm not sure about the rest of it. Stephen, welcome to the show. Stephen. Good to be here. Yeah. Thank you.
记忆与我不同，如果他以后再谈起这件事，我唯一知道发生过的事就是关于路·戴蒙德·菲利普斯的胡言乱语。这是我唯一不能确定其余部分的事。史蒂芬，欢迎来到节目。史蒂芬。很高兴来到这里。对。谢谢。
And I love your short stories. They're going to cut together. Great. So listen, I have been such a fan for so long. We don't have to go through your whole, I mean, people might find it interesting. I know they would. I know I would, but I don't want to bore you with you. So I want to know the trajectory of the late show, Stephen Colbert, because I feel like
我太喜欢你的短篇故事了。它们剪辑在一起会非常棒。所以听着，我当你的粉丝已经很久了。我们不必把你的全部，我是说，人们可能会觉得有趣。我知道他们会。我知道我会，但我不想用你的经历来烦你。所以我想知道深夜秀的发展轨迹，史蒂芬·科拜尔，因为我觉得
when the show now feels like it's different than when it began a little bit. It's different than it was a year ago. Yeah. So at the beginning, did you feel like you had to conform into Letterman's kind of format or any pressure like that? And then realized, wait a minute, I need to do my own thing here. Like what steered it in the direction it is today? Just trying a whole bunch of different stuff.
现在的节目感觉和刚开始时有点不同了。和一年前都不一样了。对。所以在刚开始时，你觉得你必须融入莱特曼的节目模式或者承受类似这样的压力吗？然后才意识到，等一下，我得在这里做我自己的事？是什么指引它走到了今天的方向？只是尝试了各种各样不同的事情。
Like when I, when I started, I had never been myself before. I was like, I'm not a host, I like hosting parties, but I'm not a host. I didn't know what that was. I'd always, even the Colbert report, that was, that was a 10 year sketch. Right. Like I did a 10 year scene. I was doing the character really, like that guy and I are not the same guy. And I worked really hard to never leave character.
就像我，当我刚开始时，我以前从来没有做过真正的自己。我心想，我不是主持人，我喜欢主持派对，但我不是个主持人。我不知道那是什么。我一直，甚至在《科拜尔报告》里，那也是，那是一个十年的小品。对。就像我演了一个十年的情景剧。我真的在扮演那个角色，就像那个家伙和我不是同一个人。我非常努力地不脱离角色。
Like I worked really hard. Like before I went on stage every night, I'd slap myself in the face hard, like really just to wake myself up and I'd look in the mirror and go, Hey, don't drop it now. Like you've been carrying this plate of glasses for like six years. Don't drop it now. What was the purpose of carrying it for six years? So I tried to stay really, you know, it's a character you wear as lightly as a hat. As the saying goes, lightly as a cap, but I still try to keep it on.
我真的很努力。就像每天晚上上台前，我都会狠狠地扇自己一巴掌，真的很用力，只是为了让自己清醒过来，然后我会看着镜子里说，嘿，现在可别搞砸了。就像你已经端着这盘玻璃杯走了六年一样。现在可别把它摔了。端着它走六年的目的是什么？所以我尽量保持，你知道的，这是一个像帽子一样轻描淡写地戴着的角色。俗话说，像帽子一样轻描淡写，但我还是尽量把它戴着。
Then I go over and I go, okay, so me, what do I want to do? I don't know. So I just kept doing different things for I'd say six months. And then one of the things I was doing at the same time was actually show running the show. I was, I didn't have a show runner. It was me. Oh yeah.
然后我走过去，心想，好吧，那么我呢，我想做什么？我不知道。所以我只是不断尝试各种不同的事，大概持续了六个月。然后我当时同时在做的事情之一，其实是担任节目的运作人。我没有运作人。就是我。哦，是的。
Which I, it was, I had the old show and I thought I could do both and I kind of lost my mind. I'm like, I can't. I'm not thinking at all about what I want to do immediately. I'm thinking about running the show. I gotta say, Steven, it really struck me. I noticed one of the last times I went there, we did a, we did a bit and I came in a little bit early, we rehearsed it and then, and then I got a knock on the door and one of your
这让我，我当时有旧的节目，我以为我能两边兼顾，结果我有点精神崩溃了。我想，我不能。我根本没在考虑我马上想做什么。我在考虑运作节目。我得说，史蒂芬，这真的震撼到我了。我注意到我最后一次去那里时，我们做了一个小品，我稍微去早了一点，我们排练了一下，然后，然后我听到敲门声，你的一个
writers, somebody on the show said, Hey, we're downstairs. Steve is rewriting the bit right now if you want to come down because he's kind of changing it. And I was so shocked by how close it was to show time and you were downstairs and you were, you were driving, you were at the computer and you were the one who was doing it and taking ideas from everybody and you were the one who was actually physically changing the bit yourself. And I thought, wow, that is so, what a high wire act you're about to go out and do the
编剧，节目组里有人说：“嘿，我们在楼下。史蒂夫现在正在重写那个段子，如果你想下来的话，因为他正在修改。”我当时太震惊了，离节目开播没多久，而你在楼下，你在开车，你在电脑前，而且是你自己在做这件事，吸取大家的意见，你实际上是亲自动手在改这个段子。我想，哇，这真是，你马上要出去上演的真是一场
show. Oh, I still do that. That never changed. That's incredible. I'm talking about the show business side of it. Like I literally had somebody, I take all the show business side of it. So all I could think about was the comedy and then that, that changed the way I did my entire day, which let me just think about, okay, I'm just a comedian or a performer here
高空走钢丝的表演。哦，我到现在还是那样。这一点从来没变。太不可思议了。我说的是演艺商业那一面。就像我 literalmente（字面意思，实际上）有个人，我包揽了所有的演艺商业部分。所以我能想的只有喜剧，然后那，那改变了我整天的工作方式，让我只是去想，好吧，我在这里只是个喜剧演员或表演者
and that's when I found out what I liked and what I didn't like about what I was doing. But that level of control was like, it was, I still, I still, I mean, I can't imagine not like working on it till the last minute. I don't, I can't imagine, I can't imagine that because every day is, is metaphor John Stewart and I used to use a back when I used to work with that guy is, it's like a distillery. Like the morning you get the pitches, that's like the corn and then you mash it with the first draft and then you take that mash and you check the alcohol level and you go, okay, let's rewrite it.
也就是在那时我弄清了我喜欢什么，以及我不喜欢我正在做的哪一部分。但那种掌控感，就像是，我还是，我还是，我是说，我无法想象不工作到最后一分钟。我不会，我无法想象，我无法想象，因为每一天都是，用我和乔恩·斯图尔特过去常说的一个比喻，回到我和那家伙共事的日子，这就像一个酿酒厂。比如早上你拿到创意，那就像是玉米，然后你把它和初稿搅碎，接着你把这个混合物拿来检查酒精浓度，然后说，好吧，我们重写吧。
That's actually to put it in the little thing and to get, get the pure alcohol out of it. And then the last rewrite, that thing in the room, right before you go on, that's where you try to make it the way I would say it. Then you try to get it in your own mouth feel and that mouth feels like that's wouldn't, that's oak aging or something, you know, that's putting in the barrel. So it turns into whiskey and you can't always do that, but it's always the goal. I'd hate to not try and it's not like you look at it go like, oh, shit, that's brandy every night.
实际上就是把它放进小容器里，从中提取出纯酒精。然后最后的重写，在房间里的那个东西，就在你上台之前，那就是你试着把它改成我会说的方式的地方。然后你试着把它放进你自己的语感里，这种语感就像是，那会是橡木陈酿什么的，你知道的，那是把它放进木桶里。所以它变成了威士忌，你不能总是做到这一点，但那是永远的目标。要是我不试一下，我会很难受，而且这并不是说你看着它，然后觉得，噢，见鬼，每晚都是白兰地。
Sometimes it's just moonshine, but you want to try to make it brandy if you can. Did you ever show up and it's in great shape right off the bat? Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I've got, well, listen, I don't know because there's a process that happens before I ever see it. There's the pitch in the morning, which I always hear and I weigh in on which of those I like, you know, we might get eight pitches and we'll ride on.
有时它只是私酿烈酒，但如果可以的话，你想尽量把它变成白兰地。你有没有过一亮相，从一开始就状态极佳的时候？有。有。我是说，我有，嗯，听着，我不知道，因为在我看到它之前有一个流程。早上有创意推介，我总是能听到，并且我会权衡我喜欢其中的哪几个，你知道的，我们可能会有八个创意，然后我们会采用
We'll ride on five or four of them and so sorry, what, what does that mean? Uh, you get eight pitches, eight pitches of jokes or eight pitches of ideas to do areas hide the stories. Like cause, cause this is for monologue or for after monologue. This is for a monologue. I mean, there are other, there are other refillables that get written more like buckets, you know, like they're not as timely, but the monologue that first 15 minutes of the show. That is for lack of a better word, like that's the national conversation.
我们会采用其中五个或四个，所以抱歉，什么，这是什么意思？呃，你有八个创意，八个笑话创意或者八个做某个领域的创意，比如隐藏的故事。就像，因为，因为这是针对独白还是独白之后。这是针对独白。我是说，还有其他，还有其他可以重复使用的内容，写的时候更像是一桶一桶的，你知道的，不像那么有时效性，但是独白，节目的前15分钟。借用一个不太准确的词，那就是全国的对话。
What are people talking about today? And we don't, we don't dictate that. We literally have a guy, we stole from Anderson Cooper's wonderful researcher named Brandon and we go, Brandon, what's the conversation? Where are the news trucks in the world right now? Right. Cause I'm going to talk about that thing that the audience has heard all day anyway and have their own anxiety about it.
大家今天都在谈论什么？我们不，我们不主导这个。我们真的有个家伙，我们从安德森·库珀那里挖来的出色的研究员，名叫布兰登，我们说，布兰登，现在大家都在聊什么？现在世界上新闻转播车都在哪里？对。因为无论如何，我要谈论的是观众一整天都在听到的那件事，并且他们对此有自己的焦虑。
What's the deadline on that? We record the show at five 30 cutoff is about five. Right. We have a late breaker team. We have a team that starts writing around three o'clock ish and the late breakers before we put their script to bed around five or five 15, we go a late breakers got any, um, many chunks. We call it.
那个的截止时间是什么时候？我们在五点半录制节目，截止时间大约是五点。没错。我们有一个突发新闻团队。我们有一个团队在大约三点钟左右开始写作，而突发新闻团队在我们把他们的剧本定稿（大约在五点或五点十五）之前，我们会去问：突发新闻团队有，嗯，有什么新料吗？我们称之为。
Anybody, anything getting chunky upstairs? We've got any many chunks and then we go, we got maxi chunks because there was just a press conference or a new vaccine just came through or whatever it is. What's going to lead all the cable news tonight is what we're thinking. What's the lead? Cause that may not be what we lead our monologue with. We might lead with something silly that just sort of like puts a little gas in the engine for the audience, but we're going to talk about whatever it is.
有没有人，楼上有没有什么重磅消息？我们有什么重磅猛料吗？然后我们会说，我们有特大猛料，因为刚刚开了一个记者招待会，或者刚出来一个新疫苗，或者诸如此类的消息。今晚所有有线电视新闻的头条会是什么，这就是我们的想法。头条是什么？因为那可能不是我们独白的头条。我们可能会以一些傻乎乎的事情开场，那就像是给观众的发动机加了一点油，但我们要谈论的是无论那是什么。
We try not to ignore whatever the thing, even if it's tragic, sadly, because we don't make jokes about it, but we don't want to say like, Hey, we, we didn't have the same experience you had as an audience tonight. That process took about six months to create the product, the way we do it. And then we've been doing that for about five, five years now. Sean mentioned at the top, when you, you know, when he was introducing you that you, you were at second city in Chicago. I know that you were a, you were part of that whole gang who were, who, by the way, who
我们尽量不忽视任何事情，即使它是悲剧，可悲的是，因为我们不拿它开玩笑，但我们不想说，嘿，我们，我们今晚没有和你作为观众一样的经历。那个过程花了大约六个月来打造这个产品，用我们现在的这种方式。然后我们这样做了大约五、五年了。肖恩在开场时提到，当你，你知道的，当他介绍你时，你在芝加哥的“第二城”。我知道你曾是，你是那帮人中的一员，顺便问一下，谁是
were your kind of your contemporaries when you were in Chicago? Cause everybody has kind of different classes that they were with. Yeah. Yeah. Well, there's, there's two different things. There's, there's the people you watched where you wanted to be your contemporaries. And then there's the people you performed with, but in your mind, those people you watched are also like the people you were watching.
你在芝加哥时的同辈人？因为每个人都有不同的同期学员。对。对。嗯，有，有两种不同的情况。一种是，你看着他们并希望成为你的同辈人的人。另一种是，与你同台演出的人，但在你心目中，那些你看着的人也是就像你在观看的人。
Like the people I watched, the people who I first saw improvise actually, not at second city, but at this little club in Chicago called cross, cross currents, was under the Belmont L and just really, really divey little place. Dave Pascuesi. Do you know guys, Dave? Yeah. Pascuesi was the first guy I ever saw. I went, Oh, I want to do that.
就像我看着的人，我第一次看到即兴表演的人，实际上不是在第二城，而是在芝加哥的一家小俱乐部，叫“十字流”，在贝尔蒙特L地铁线下面，那是一个非常非常破旧的小地方。戴夫·帕斯库西。你们认识戴夫吗？对。帕斯库西是我见过的第一个让我说，哦，我想做那个。
I want to, I, whatever he's got, I want that, that little secret he has when he walks on stage. I don't know what it is, but I, I always want to know what it is. Like how can you, today, I still like, I kind of still want to be Dave Pascuesi, especially his ability to improvise, but who else was there? Um, Mike Myers was on stage and, um, Tim Meadows was on stage, no, Corel was, Corel was essentially my same generation. He was about, he was about a year ahead of me.
我想，无论他拥有什么，我都想要，他在走上舞台时拥有的那个小秘密。我不知道那是什么，但我，我总是想知道那是什么。比如你怎么能，今天，我还是觉得，我某种程度上仍然想成为戴夫·帕斯库西，尤其是他即兴发挥的能力，但还有谁在那儿？嗯，迈克·迈尔斯在台上，嗯，蒂姆·梅多斯在台上，不对，卡瑞尔，卡瑞尔基本上和我是一代人。他大概，他大概比我早一年。
Second city works like a wrap. Yeah. Like you, you come in and you learn, you learn like the last 40 years of material. When you do that on the road, he was in that process, like six months to a year ahead of me in that process. And what about like Amy, Amy Sideris hired on the same day because there's a big casting call every year. Like they, they'll 300 people come in and they pick like five, four, six.
第二城的工作方式就像流水线。对。比如你进来，然后你学习，你学习过去40年的素材。当你在巡演中这样做时，他在那个流程中，比我领先大约六个月到一年。那么像艾米，艾米·西达里斯是同一天被雇用的吗，因为每年都有一次大型试镜。比如，他们，会有300人来，然后他们选出大概五、四、六个人。
My year, the people who were hired that August were, which was 1988, I guess it was me, Rose Abdu, Amy Sideris, Paul Dinello, and Chris Farley, and Greg Hallman, but Chris Farley. So first six months I toured with Farley. He toured around the country. He could do no, no wrong to me. Funniest guy. You know, people don't talk about Farley enough. People don't.
我那年，8月份被雇用的人，我想那是1988年，有我、罗斯·阿卜杜、艾米·西达里斯、保罗·迪内洛、克里斯·法利、格雷格·霍尔曼，还有克里斯·法利。所以前六个月我和法利一起巡演。他在全国各地巡演。在我看来他做什么都不会错。最搞笑的人。你知道，人们对法利的讨论还不够。人们没有。
I agree. He deserves a deeper memory in comedy. He's written off as just kind of like this big dumb sort of goofy, did big physical stuff, but there was such a purpose there. It was so sharp, right? He is. You're right. That's how he's written off.
我同意。他在喜剧界值得更深刻的记忆。他被轻描淡写地认为只是那种又大又笨、有点滑稽、做些大幅度形体动作的人，但那其中是有真正目的的。他是那么敏锐，对吧？他是。你说得对。他就是被这样轻描淡写地对待的。
Not a dumb guy. It's so specific and so, and it was so spot on and it was so, so specific, right? So spot on. Just, he just, he and Sideris had this thing. Like I remember that I saw them before I worked with them. I saw them on stage because they were actually, we were hired, but they were actually placed in the company first. And so I was literally still like waiting tables there.
不是个笨蛋。它是如此具体，如此，而且是如此精准，对吧，如此精准。只是，他和西达里斯有一种默契。我记得在我跟他们合作之前我就见过他们。我在舞台上见过他们，因为他们实际上，我们是被雇用的，但他们实际上先被安排进了剧团。所以我字面意义上还在那里端盘子。
And I saw, I saw both of them on stage and I went, who are those people? The first thing I ever saw Amy say is she walked on stage, door burst open, there's this tiny little bundle of energy. She goes, oh my God, you've got a wet bar and just starts laughing like that and runs over and goes, I don't want to, I don't want to, now I want to see the cocktails she's going to make. And I went, I want to, I want to work with her. And then me and Paul and Amy ended up essentially working together almost every day for like
我看到他们俩在舞台上，我说，那些人是谁？我第一次看到艾米·西达里斯表演是她走上舞台，门突然打开，这小团能量爆发出来。她说：“哦，天哪，你有个湿吧（带水槽的酒吧）！”然后就这样大笑起来，跑过去说：“我不想，我不想，现在我想看看她要调什么鸡尾酒了。”当时我就想，我想跟她合作。然后我和保罗、艾米最终基本上几乎每天都在一起工作，大约
17 years. And you created strangers with candy. We were like, we were in a common law marriage for the next seven years. It's great. I think candy is one of my favorites. Yeah. It's fantastic. Did you, I heard that once you described Amy as like an idiot savant without the savant,
17年。你们创作了《缀网之蛾》。我们就像是，我们在接下来的七年里维持着事实婚姻。太棒了。我觉得《缀网之蛾》是我的最爱之一。对。太棒了。你，我听说你曾经把艾米描述为一个没有学者风范的学者型痴呆症患者，
is that true? As a, as a joke, as a joke to her, to her. Oh no, she knows, she knows, no, that, I, yes, I think that, I think that might be her own accurate. That might be her own interpretation of herself. She would sit in the corner as we would like write change with candy. And of course everything is written for her and around her. It's all built around like, what can we build around her?
是这样吗？作为一个玩笑，对她开的玩笑，对她。噢不，她知道，她知道，不，那个，是的，我想，我想那可能是她自己的准确。那可能是她对自己的一种解读。当我们在写《缀网之蛾》时，她会坐在角落里。当然，一切都是为她而写，并围绕着她展开的。这完全是围绕着——我们能围绕她构建什么？
And Paul and I, it'd be like three o'clock in the morning and we'd be slapping on the keys going, okay, where do we go with this? And we'd be just sitting there in like the horror of the clock whizzing on the wall, like the hands going around, like we have to shoot this tomorrow. And then Amy would go like, but what if it was a squirrel? And we'd go, what? She's like, what did I say? Like, you said something about a squirrel, and it would be exactly the right thing in
而保罗和我，常常会在凌晨三点钟疯狂敲击键盘，心想：好吧，我们这个情节该往哪儿发展？我们就会坐在那里，伴随着墙上滴答作走的时钟带来的恐惧，看着指针转动——我们明天就要拍摄这个了。然后艾米会突然说：“但是如果那是一只松鼠呢？”我们就会说：“什么？”她说：“我说了什么？”就像，你刚刚说了关于松鼠的话，而那恰好是那一刻最完美的主意。
that moment. And she wouldn't necessarily know that she had absorbed every problem we were trying to surmount. And she would just blurred out exactly the right answer exactly when we needed it. So the wheels are always turning inside that little coconut size skull of hers. But she's one of those people who makes me laugh more than I just, I can't, she's like a drug to me. Yeah.
那一刻。而她甚至不一定意识到她已经吸收了我们试图克服的所有问题。她只是在我们最需要的时候脱口而出最正确的答案。所以，在她那个椰子大小的头脑里，齿轮总是在不停地转动。但她就是那种能让我笑得最厉害的人，我就是，我不能，她对我来说就像毒品一样。对。
I love it too. But speaking of that, Steven, like just thinking really fast, you, you have such a fast brain. And I love that you, you're like, uh, you know, wishing you were had great, as great of improv skills as some of the people you grew up with. But you do. I mean, your brain works so fast. Is it frustrating to be with people like you who aren't as fast as I am really slow? Is this agony to actually be doing anything with you to dain, to condescend, to appear
我也很喜欢。但说到这个，斯蒂芬，就凭你转动得极快的大脑，你，你的大脑转得太快了。我喜欢你，你就像是，呃，你知道的，希望自己能和跟你一起成长的一些人一样拥有伟大的即兴表演技巧。但你确实有。我是说，你的大脑运转得太快了。和你们这样的人在一起会让人感到沮丧吗？那些不像我这么慢的人？和你一起做任何事都是一种煎熬吗？去屈尊俯就，去屈尊在
on your podcast? Uh-huh. Are you ripping paper? No, I am enjoying myself. I'm enjoying myself. No, but is it frustrating being around people who don't, who don't think as fast as you or work as fast as you or work as hard as you or anything like that? No, I actually don't think of myself as that great of an improviser.
你的播客里露面？呃——哼。你在撕纸吗？没有，我很享受。我很享受。不，但是和那些思维没有你快、工作没有你快、工作没有你努力或者类似这样的人在一起，会感到沮丧吗？不，我其实并不觉得自己是个那么了不起的即兴表演者。
I mean, I, I know a lot of people who are better than I am because I don't think it's necessarily about being fast. I think it's being like honestly reactive because, you know, I, not to get too spiritual here, but the first guy took any classes with the Del Close. And while there, you know, there are people who have their own opinions or pros and cons about, you know, Del Close, I don't have much of an experience with him. But he, one of the things he said was that don't think that it's you, don't think it's you that have to do this.
我是说，我，我认识很多比我更好的人，因为我认为这不一定取决于反应快。我认为这取决于真正地做出反应，因为，你知道的，不是要在这里变得太过于精神层面，但我上的第一堂课的老师是德尔·克罗斯。虽然在那里，你知道，人们对德尔·克罗斯有他们自己的看法或赞贬不一，我对他没有太多的经历。但他，他曾说过的一件事是，不要以为是你，不要以为是你必须做到这一点。
You actually have to be reactive and just the universe is going to do it. If you actually do it right, it's, it's just happening. You won't, you won't know who did it if you do it right. And I think that, that's sort of in some ways the opposite of quickness. That's vulnerability. That's vulnerability. And there are people who are great vulnerable performers who I'm incredibly jealous of because I still have a need to please and that can get in the way of me actually being a good
你实际上必须做出反应，宇宙会搞定它的。如果你真的做对了，它就会自然发生。如果你做对了，你甚至不会知道是谁干的。我认为，这在某种程度上与敏捷恰恰相反。那是脆弱性。那是脆弱性。有些人是伟大的脆弱型表演者，我对他们嫉妒得要命，因为我仍然有取悦他人的需求，这可能会妨碍我成为一个真正优秀的
improviser because you want to score. Don't you consider what you do on, on your show, your conversations with people as, as improv? Yeah. I mean, I do. Sure. Being able to just be on your feet and be listening. And then.
即兴表演者，因为你想得分。难道你不认为你在节目中所做的事情——你与人们的对话——就是即兴表演吗？对。我是说，我确实这么认为。当然。能够随机应变并且懂得倾听。然后。
Yeah. It's not, I mean, to me, the old show was more of like improv because there was a character choice. And then you were, you were making, you were making performance choices in the moment. That was really improvisation. First one, I'd really, especially now in COVID, I just tried to actually have a conversation with someone. It must be kind of harder now, just being yourself in a certain way than spending all
对。这不——我是说，对我来说，以前的节目更像是即兴表演，因为有一个角色选择。然后你在，你在当下做出表演选择。那才是真正的即兴表演。第一个节目，我真的，尤其现在在疫情期间，我只是试着真正和某人进行一次对话。现在这样肯定更难吧，某种程度上做回自己，比起花那么多
those years where you could, you were playing a character and getting, it's because you have to be much more honest again, without being too sort of, you know, corny, but you're being much more, just being yourself and being vulnerable in that way is probably more difficult. Yes or no. But it was for me. Yeah. But it is for me. I mean, now I wouldn't want to do that old guy.
年你可以扮演一个角色并获得，这是因为你必须再次变得更加诚实，而不至于显得太老套，但你要变得更加，只是做你自己并在那种方式下表现出脆弱，这可能更加困难。是还是不是。但对我来说是的。对。但对我来说是的。我是说，现在我可不想演那个老头了。
Right, right. I mean, I didn't want to do that old guy anymore anyway. That's why I left. It's not like I got fired. I still liked doing him, but I wanted to leave while I still liked it. And I never intended to be doing what I'm doing right now. As a matter of fact, I already made the decision to leave that show before I was offered this one.
对，对。我是说，反正我也不想再演那个老头了。这就是我离开的原因。并不是我被解雇了。我仍然喜欢演他，但我想在还喜欢的时候离开。而且我从没打算做我现在正在做的事情。事实上，在有人向我提供这个节目之前，我已经决定离开那个节目了。
That was, this was 100% a happy accident. Oh wow. I had a whole other plan. I had a whole other thing I was going to do. What was that plan? What were you going to do? I still want to do it. I don't remember to steal it, but I, honest to God, that's how show biz I am.
那是，这百分之百是一次快乐的意外。哦，哇。我本来有完全不同的计划。我本来有别的事情要做。那个计划是什么？你原本要做什么？我还是想做那件事。我不记得要把它偷走，但我，说实话，这就是我作为演艺圈人士的表现。
It's registered trademark. I was going to put that character into a narrative. I was going to put that character into an honest to God, like, half hour comedy. You should. Oh, but you still can do that. I wanted to follow, I wanted to follow what he was going to do next. Yeah, but nobody can steal that idea because you play the guy. Half hour comedy.
那是注册商标。我原本打算把那个角色放进一个叙事中。我原本打算把那个角色放进一个货真价实的、半小时的喜剧里。你应该这么做。哦，但你还是可以做那个。我想追踪，我想追踪他接下来会做什么。对，但没人能偷走那个创意，因为你演过那个家伙。半小时的喜剧。
Yeah. Starring like sort of like the character from Colbert's report and just like a single camera or a multi-camera. I can tell you what it was going to be. I'm going to tell you what was going to go with it is that in 2012, what gave me the idea was that I had all this money because I started a super pack. I started, I raised $1.3 million, which scared the, but Jesus out of me, by the way, we started as a game.
对。主演就像有点像《扣扣报告》里的那个角色，而且是用单机位还是多机位。我可以告诉你那本来会是什么。我要告诉你它原本会怎样：在2012年，给我这个灵感的是，我当时有很多钱，因为我成立了一个超级政治行动委员会。我成立了，我筹集了130万美元，顺便说一句，这把我吓得魂飞魄散。我们最初是把它当成一个游戏。
Like I, on the old show, I like to always just do everything real, you know, and as my publicist once said to me, carry, carry by like my dear friend. She once said to me, Hey, I need to ask about this running for president thing. Everybody's calling me and I just want to get, you know, everything nailed down here. So I understand is this, is this a joke or are you running for real? And I said, well, if it wasn't real, it wouldn't be a joke. She goes, got it, got it, got it. And that was the way we did.
就像我，在以前的节目里，我总是喜欢把一切都当作真的来做，你知道的，正如我的公关人员曾经对我说的那样，凯莉，凯莉就像我亲爱的朋友。她曾对我说：“嘿，我需要问一下关于竞选总统这件事。每个人都在打电话给我，我只是想把所有事情都落实清楚，这样我好明白，这，这是一个玩笑，还是你是来真的？”我说：“嗯，如果这不是真的，那就不是个玩笑。”她说：“明白了，明白了，明白了。”这就是我们做事的方式。
I wanted to do everything for real. I really had a super pack. I really wanted to raise money because I really wanted to see, I wanted to be the joke. The character was the joke. What made it easier for me is that anytime you would approach a subject, there is a base code of joke because the character is a joke. I could approach any subject and there would always be some level of comedy because the character would be the joke.
我想把一切都变成真的。我真的有一个超级政治行动委员会。我真的想筹集资金，因为我真的想看看，我想成为这个笑话本身。这个角色就是个笑话。对我来说更容易的是，每当你接触一个主题时，都会有一个基础代码的笑话，因为这个角色本身就是个笑话。我可以接触任何主题，并且总会有某种程度的喜剧效果，因为这个角色就是笑话。
And now there always has to be a joke. And that's what's harder about now. I don't have to turn that extra knob to do the character. And there are times when I really, I really do enjoy being myself. And I actually enjoy interviewing people more as myself, but I think it requires more of my writers in a way because they actually, our joke per minute ratio has to be much better because it's set ups and punchlines. Do you give yourself the credit that you deserve for being such a great actor by playing that
而现在必须时刻都有笑话。这就是现在更难的地方。我不必为了扮演那个角色而额外去扭动那个旋钮了。有时我真的，我真的很享受做我自己。而且我实际上更喜欢以我自己的身份去采访别人，但我认为这在某种程度上对我的编剧提出了更高要求，因为实际上，我们的每分钟笑料比率必须更高，因为这全靠铺垫和抖包袱。你有没有给予自己应得的赞赏，认为自己把那个角色演得那么好，而且没有挤眉弄眼，没有暗示，以至于……
character as well as you did with no winking, no nut to the point where... By the way, Jason, sorry, for tracing Wisconsin, we're talking about the Colbert Report. Just so people know what we've never said, what we just keep saying the character. You played a fervent right wing, what would you call it? Pundit. Yeah. Pundit. So that took acting skills.
顺便说一句，杰森，抱歉，对于追溯威斯康星州，我们在谈论《扣扣报告》。只是为了让大家知道，我们之前从没说过，我们只是一直在说那个角色。你扮演了一个狂热的右翼，你会怎么称呼他？名嘴。对。名嘴。所以那需要演技。
I question... Hold on one second. I'm going to interrupt you because I'm the host. I question whether Tracey in Wisconsin, hearing Colbert Report, if that helps her any more than knowing that I'm Stephen Colbert and saying character because if they don't know Stephen Colbert, you should do a character. I don't think Colbert Report is going to tip them off. Okay.
我质疑……等一下。我要打断你，因为我是主持人。我怀疑威斯康星州的特蕾西听到《扣扣报告》时，是否比知道我是斯蒂芬·科尔伯特并说是个角色对她更有帮助，因为如果他们不知道斯蒂芬·科尔伯特，你该去演个角色。我不认为《扣扣报告》能点醒他们。好吧。
Just calm down about all of that. And let's just keep going. Wow. I'm trying to give you the hostility that I get. I got it. It's coming through. It's coming through. And that's the cycle of abuse.
关于所有这些，冷静点。让我们继续。哇。我是在向你展现我所感受到的敌意。我懂了。传达到了。传达到了。这就是虐待的循环。
That's the cycle of abuse. Right. Still trying to finish my goddamn question. Stephen. Oh, well, we'd love you to fucking start it. Hey, Stephen. Hi. So given all of that great raw acting talent, do you have any desire to play characters?
这就是虐待的循环。对。还在试图说完我该死的提问。斯蒂芬。哦，好吧，我们很乐意你他妈的开始提问。嘿，斯蒂芬。嗨。那么，鉴于所有那些伟大的演戏天赋，你有什么演角色的愿望吗？
Like have like a acting career in and around your show? In and around my show. Now, the show takes all of my time, you know, like I'd much rather produce other people's shows. Like I'd much rather take this and help people the way I was helped. That's what I'd like to do. Like while I'm doing my show, I think to really do a good job, I'd have to like stop doing the show.
比如在你的节目期间及周边拥有一个演艺生涯？在我的节目期间及周边。现在，这个节目占去了我所有的精力，你知道，我宁愿去制作别人的节目。比如我宁愿拿着这个去帮助别人，就像我曾经被帮助过一样。这正是我想要做的。就像当我在做我的节目时，我认为要真正做好，我得停下这个节目才行。
And I enjoy doing the show. I don't want to be, I don't think I could do like a side hustle as an actor. But could you, could you see yourself doing like you were just mentioning, you know, the show that you wanted to do based on your character from Colbert Rapport, could you imagine taking that character and producing it and potentially writing it at whatever and running it and having another actor say like a Lou Diamond Phillips playing you. Is that something that you would consider? And again, knowing that, wait a second, I was going to say no.
而且我很享受做这个节目。我不愿意，我不认为我能兼职当演员。但你能，你能想象自己做你刚才提到的那种事吗，根据你在《扣扣报告》中的角色创作的你想做的节目，你能想象把那个角色拿来制作，可能还要编写剧本，不管怎样，然后运营它，让另一个演员来演，比如让卢·戴·菲利普斯扮演你。那是你会考虑的事情吗？再说一次，要知道，等一下，我本来要说不。
Okay. I was going to say no until you said Lou Diamond Phillips. Just to get under Conan's. There could be a natural sort of war angle to it as well. Just knowing that Conan is so mad at him because Conan's like, where does he get off, right? Conan could do like a, like a guest arc, like a stunt arc on it, producing itself. So, but could you, no, but all bits aside, could you, could you see yourself producing like that idea that you had that you wanted for you producing it for somebody else?
好吧。我本来要说不，直到你说了卢·戴·菲利普斯。为了激怒柯南。这其中也可能有一种自然的战争角度。要知道柯南对这一点非常生气，因为柯南会想：“他凭什么？”，对吧？柯南可以在上面客串演出，来个特技客串，由它自己制作。所以，但是你能，不，抛开所有段子不谈，你能，你能想象自己制作像你当初为你自己想要的那种创意，把它制作出来给别人演吗？
Yeah. I mean, I got that. I'd rather, I'd rather, I'd rather do something else because that I specifically, there was things I wanted to do with him that were ways, what I liked about him was how he climbed up against the real world. Like going out into the real world and really upset people almost every time I did it. It was so fun. And now I honestly, I like people who like me as much as the next person.
对。我是说，我有过那个想法。我宁愿，我宁愿，我宁愿做点别的，因为那个角色，我具体想用他做一些事情，我喜欢他的一点在于他是如何与现实世界发生碰撞的。比如走入现实世界，几乎每次我这么做都会把人们气得半死。那太有趣了。而现在，说实话，我喜欢那些像其他人一样喜欢我的人。
And so now, honest to God, like, you know, I actually don't, I love the audience. I don't, some people have like a hostile relationship to their audience. Like I never feel like it's the audience's fault. If the show doesn't go well, I never blame them. It's always me. That's my job. They're, they're amateurs. Exactly what you mean.
所以现在，说实话，就像，你知道的，我实际上不，我爱观众。有些人与他们的观众有一种敌对关系。就像我从来不觉得那是观众的错。如果节目没做好，我从不怪他们。永远都是我的错。那是我的工作。他们，他们是业余的。完全明白你的意思。
Yeah. And I, I like people to like me. And so this is such a different job. Whereas that old job, I, I, it was okay if they didn't like me. That was kind of the purpose of him going out into the world was to see what this kind of character would be clanging up in his most extreme state with real people who weren't in on it. And given that, do you think in today's political climate that, that you could do that show
对。而且我喜欢别人喜欢我。所以这是一份完全不同的工作。而在以前那份工作里，我，我不在乎他们是否喜欢我。这正是他走向世界的那种目的，去看看这种类型的角色在与不知情的真实人们进行最极端的碰撞时会是怎样的。鉴于此，你认为在当今的政治气候下，你今天还能做那个节目吗？
today? And, and no, I don't think, I think it would, it would, it would poke the bear too much. Wouldn't it? I think it would be too dark. I think our political climate has gotten. I could feel it. That's one of the reasons why I wanted to leave is I no longer wanted to, as I said before,
而且，不，我不认为，我认为这会，这会，这会过分激怒那头熊，不是吗？我觉得这会太黑暗了。我认为我们的政治气候已经变得。我能感觉到。这也是我想离开的原因之一，我不再想去，正如我之前所说，
that I, I no longer wanted to sip that cup of poison because you had to sip a little bit or you had to titrate it a little bit to go do the character. And I just couldn't even look at those people anymore. And now I would never, can you imagine having to leapfrog the guy who was just to be worse than him? No, I know. Because he literally quoted my old character at times, literally like word for word reaction you get when you go back to the South.
我不再想啜饮那杯毒药了，因为你必须喝上一小口，或者你必须稍微调整一下剂量才能去扮演那个角色。而我甚至再也无法直视那些人了。现在我绝对不会——你能想象不得不去超越那个刚刚出现、比他还糟糕的家伙吗？不，我知道。因为他有时真的逐字逐句地引用我以前那个角色……当你回到南方时受到的反应。
You're from, you're from the South. Yeah. I'm from South Carolina. From South Carolina. All roads lead North from South Carolina. Sure. Nice. Sure.
你是从，你是从南方来的。对。我来自南卡罗来纳州。来自南卡罗来纳州。在南卡罗来纳州，条条大路通北方。确实。不错。确实。
That's good. What's it like? It's fine. I mean, I don't know. You still family there? Yeah. Yeah. And I married a girl from there.
挺好的。那里怎么样？挺好的。我是说，我不知道。你还有家人在那里吗？对。对。而且我娶了个那里的姑娘。
So like there's no debate about where we go when we have time. And we like have a play. We have a house like right across the street from her sister. It's like really. That's great. And her, and her parents live in a block, a block and a half away and my sister lives about a half a mile away. And so.
所以，当我们有时间时，对于我们要去哪里没有任何争论。我们喜欢有个地方。我们在她姐姐家街对面有一栋房子。感觉真的很棒。那太好了。而且她，她的父母就住在隔了一个半街区的地方，我姐姐住在大概半英里远的地方，所以。
You've been telling, you don't have to wear a heavy disguise for, for, for protection. No, no, no, I don't think I, I'm happy to say I don't think anybody cares about me. Yeah. Right. We do. Here at smartless, we do. I don't get fanned at and I don't get hostile that I'm just unless I'm sitting in the guest chair.
你一直在说，你不需要为了保护而做重度伪装。不，不，不，我想我，我高兴地说，我想没有人会在乎我。yeah。对。我们会的。在“聪明无赖”（SmartLess）播客里，我们在乎。我不会被狂热追星，我也不会遇到敌意，我只是——除非我坐在嘉宾椅上。
Is anybody, cause you got, you come from a large family like me, but not as nearly as large as yours. Is anybody else in the family like, first of all, 11 kids you grew up with, there's got to be a gay one in there and, and, and not that we know, all right, well, hang on, not that we know, hang on, hang in there, the door is open, sure. Door is open. What was it like growing up in such a massive organization, normal, you know, whatever happens to your childhood is normal.
有没有人，因为你来自一个像我一样大家庭，但远没有你的那么大。家里还有其他人像，首先，你和11个孩子一起长大，里面肯定有一个是同性恋，而且，而且，不是我们知道的，好吧，等一下，不是我们知道的，好吧，坚持住，大门敞开，当然。大门敞开。在一个如此庞大的组织中长大是什么感觉，正常，你知道的，童年发生的一切都是正常的。
Right. Right. Right. So it felt perfectly normal. It wasn't until I had no sense of it, so I was in first grade. So I'm in first grade and the very first day of first grade, we all, the teacher I forgot Mrs. Poole, I think her name was, and we all had to sit up on the back of our seat, like with our butts are on the back of our seat, our feet are in the seat of the seat and we're
对。对。对。所以感觉完全正常。直到我上一年级，我才对此毫无概念。所以我上一年级，一年级的第一天，我们所有人，我忘了那个老师叫普尔太太，我想是叫这个名字，我们都必须坐在椅子的靠背上，就像我们的屁股坐在椅子的靠背上，我们的脚踩在椅子的座位上，我们
all to sit up there and she's going to hold up her hand fingers. And when she gets to the number of children in your family, sit down because she's trying to get to know us and she gets to 10 and I'm still sitting up on the back of my seat and she thinks that I can't count. She's like, I'm the troubled child because that's why she's doing it, to see if kids know how to count. And this is 1969 in South Carolina. This is just like two steps away from to kill a mockingbird, this community I'm in.
都得坐在那上面，然后她会举起手指。当她数到你家里孩子的数量时，你就要坐下来，因为她正在努力认识我们，当她数到10时，我还坐在椅子的靠背上，她以为我不会数数。她觉得我是那个有问题的小孩，因为她这么做就是为了看看孩子们会不会数数。这是1969年的南卡罗来纳州。这离《杀死一只知更鸟》只有两步之遥，我所在的这个社区。
And the yules live right around the corner. And so that's when I found out that it was unusual that you had that many kids in your family. And are you trying to replicate that? Do you have a bunch of kids running around there? How many do you have? I'm trying to, but so far just three, just the three, just three, but I'm not giving up.
而尤尔一家就住在转角处。所以就在那时我发现，家里有那么多孩子原来是一件不寻常的事。那你也在试图复制那种生活吗？你有一大群孩子在周围跑来跑去吗？你有几个孩子？我正试图这么做，但到目前为止只有三个，只有三个，就三个，但我不会放弃。
Do they, do they know what you do? And my wife is listening. I'm not. We're both in our, we're both in our late fifties, but you know what? Have you heard of Abraham? Yeah. This is very threatening, man. Again, you might want to bring the tone down.
他们，他们知道你是做什么的吗？我妻子正在听。我才不。我们俩都，我们俩都快六十岁了，但你知道吗？你听说过亚伯拉罕吗？这太具有威胁性了，伙计。再说一次，你可能想缓和一下语气。
Go ahead, Jason. Do they, do they know what you do? Do they appreciate you? Your humor? Do they give it up? Or is it the toughest audience in the world? Like the rest of us? I, it's a tough audience.
继续吧，杰森。他们，他们知道你是做什么的吗？他们欣赏你吗？你的幽默？他们买账吗？还是说这是世界上最难对付的观众？就像我们其他人一样？我，这是个很难对付的观众。
Yeah. It's a tough audience. I mean, I think they appreciate what dad does. Yeah. Tough audience. Every still a good audience. That's nice. She's my audience now because I got no audience when she, when she comes in and sits in the
对。这是个很难对付的观众。我是说，我觉得他们欣赏爸爸所做的事。对。很难对付的观众。依然是个好观众。那挺好的。她现在是我的观众，因为当我，当她进来坐在
extra little red chair in the storage closet where I'm doing the late show right now. That's it. Like that's as good. I mean, I, I actually said this on the show the other night when I started off, I thought like, God, I wish I could make an audience laugh the way I make Evie laugh. I, I could make it, but honestly, God, because it was like, I could feel like the honesty and like the intimacy because really that intimacy, like, what do you want? You like, there's a sense of community with an audience if you get it right, you know?
储藏室里那个多余的小红椅子上时，我录《深夜秀》正是在那里，我就没有别的观众了。就是这样。就像那样好。我是说，我，我前几天在节目刚开始时就这样说过，我想，天哪，我要是能让观众笑得像我让伊薇笑那样就好了。我，我可以做到，但说实话，因为那种感觉就像，我能感受到那种诚实和亲密感，因为真正的这种亲密感，就像，你想要什么？你喜欢，如果你做对了，观众会有一种社区感，你知道吗？
And now she's it. That's it. Like she's the one I'm making laugh. And it's kind of joyful and kind of wonderful. And as sad as the last year has been, that's been a marvelous thing. Cause she was, she, she and my, the kids were my crew down in South Carolina. We bugged out one year ago yesterday, we left the Ed Sullivan Theater and we went down to South Carolina to help take care of her folks who were like, you know, in their nineties
而现在她就是全部。就是这样——她是我要逗笑的人。这既充满欢乐又相当美妙。尽管过去的一年很悲伤，但那一直是一件了不起的事情。因为她，她和我的，孩子们是我在南卡罗来纳州的剧组。整整一年前的昨天，我们离开了埃德·沙利文剧院，去了南卡罗来纳州，去照顾她的父母，他们当时，你知道的，已经九十多岁了，
and they couldn't have any, anybody coming and help them. So it was just really Evie and her sister taking care of them. So we were down there right down the street and we couldn't let crew into the house. We had a satellite truck parked on the front lawn, killing the grass and they ran cables in through a spare bedroom window where we packed foam around it and tried to keep the bugs out. And I put a kitchen stool next to an old desk from her family and there was a TV in there. I could put graphics up on it.
而且他们不能让任何人来帮助他们。所以实际上只有伊薇和她的姐姐在照顾他们。所以我们就在那里，就在街区下游，我们不能让剧组人员进屋。我们的前草坪上停着一辆卫星转播车，压坏了草皮，他们把电缆穿过备用卧室的窗户拉进来，我们在周围塞满了泡沫塑料试图把虫子挡在外面。我在她家族的一张旧书桌旁放了一张厨房凳子，里面有一台电视。我可以在上面播放图表。
And the first thing is my, my middle son, my, my daughter's, you know, in her twenties and out there with a job, but she was working, she was like working online in the kitchen and my eldest son was my crew for the first couple of months. And then he's like, I'm, he was finishing up colleges. Like I'm literally not going to graduate if I keep doing this dad. So his younger brother who was finishing up high school, both of them robbed with their senior years, you know, they're worse, they're worse things, but it was, I felt bad for him. Then he took over in tag team.
首先是我的，我的二儿子，我的女儿，你知道的，她二十多岁了，出去工作了，但她在工作，她当时在厨房里在线办公，我的大儿子在前几个月里是我的剧组工作人员。然后他说：“我，”他当时快大学毕业了，“如果我继续这样做，爸爸，我真的就毕不了业了。”所以他的弟弟当时快高中毕业了，他们两个人的高三生活都被剥夺了，你知道的，虽然有更糟的事，但我为他感到难过。然后他接替了哥哥，兄弟俩开始轮流搭档。
And then both of them are like, mom, like, well, and we won't be, I won't graduate from high school. So then Evie took over and then she was my crew and which was just kind of great. And it was really like the old 19th century. Everybody's going to pitch in and help dad down at the lumber mill because we've got the pine, you know, the new lodge pole pines are coming in and we've got to make flooring or whatever they did in the 19th century. So did they laugh at the jokes?
然后他们俩都说：“妈妈，好吧，我，我高中毕不了业了。”然后伊薇接手了，接着她成了我的剧组工作人员，这真是太棒了。这真的就像19世纪的老传统。每个人都要出力，帮爸爸在木材厂干活，因为我们有松木，你知道的，新的洛奇波尔松木运到了，我们得做地板，或者他们在19世纪做的那些事。那么他们会为笑话笑吗？
No, Evie would laugh at the jokes for the, I don't think that my boys cracked a smile for five months because that's how long we did it. But they weren't really paying attention either. But what they did, but they, because they were just doing the technical aspects of it, but it was like lighting, sound cameras, switching over like channels and everything, communicating with the people on their own, they're on the headset talking to the virtual control. Basically a live show.
不，伊薇会为笑话发笑，但我认为我的儿子们有五个月时间连嘴角都没咧一下，因为我们做了那么长时间。但其实他们也没怎么注意。但他们做的是，因为他们只负责技术方面的工作，但那就像灯光、声音、摄像机、切换频道等等，在耳机里与其他人沟通，他们戴着耳机与虚拟控制室通话。基本上是一个直播节目。
No way. Live show. I'm 100%. Craig, they're on the kids on the headset going, hold on, dad, we're switching satellites or whatever. That's what my boys are doing for me. And then my daughter's doing my makeup and then CBS catches when they go, oh, we could do this.
不会吧。直播节目。我百分之百确定。克赖格，孩子们戴着耳机说：“等等，爸爸，我们在切换卫星”之类的话。这就是我的儿子们为我做的事情。然后我女儿帮我化妆，接着CBS发现了，他们说：“哦，我们可以这样做。
It's a lot cheaper. Uh-huh. Well, we actually, we actually had to get a union waiver was like an emergency. Of course. Like you literally, because it was emergency COVID, the union said, okay, you can do this. But it was kind of an amazing thing, but they got to see what my, I loved it because I think it's very helpful for everybody to become an adult to see their parents as human. Yeah, of course.
这便宜得多。”呃——哼。嗯，我们实际上，我们实际上不得不申请工会豁免，就像是紧急情况。当然。就像你字面意义上的，因为那是疫情紧急情况，工会说：“好吧，你们可以这样做。”但这真是一件了不起的事情，但他们得以看到我的，我喜欢这样，因为我认为对于每个人来说，看到父母作为普通人的一面是非常有帮助的。对，当然。
You know, I lost my dad when I was pretty young and I was robbed of that ability to see him as not Olympian, to not see him, to see him as a human being. And so there's something stunting about your development if you don't get to see your parents as human. And they 100% saw their dad as human going like literally like in the middle of the monologue, just throwing my glasses across. I'm going, I don't know how the fuck I'm supposed to do this with no audience and like no sense of timing.
你知道的，我很年轻的时候就失去了父亲，我被剥夺了那种能力——无法把他看作不是奥林匹斯山上的神，无法看到他，无法把他看作一个普通人。所以如果你看不到父母人性化的一面，你的成长就会受到某种阻碍。他们百分之百地看到了他们父亲人性化的一面，就字面意义上而言，在独白进行到一半时，直接把眼镜扔了出去，然后说：“我他妈不知道在没有观众、没有丝毫节奏感的情况下该怎么做。”
Like I took the goddamn job at the late show, not because I had ever really like harbored this dream of being a late night talk, cause this is real, this is a real late night. Like I didn't know what this job was like until I did it. No idea. I mean, my respect for like the Jimmy's and the Conan's and your Dave's and your J's and your Johnny's and your Steve Allen's and your Jack Parr's and your Dick Cavits went, I already liked them. I'd never had it like I already liked them, but my respect went through if I went, oh
就像我接下《深夜秀》这个该死的工作，并不是因为我真的曾经怀揣过成为深夜脱口秀主持人的梦想，因为这是真的，这是一个真正的深夜节目。就像我在做这份工作之前，根本不知道这工作是什么样的。完全没有概念。我是说，我对吉米们、柯南们、你们的戴夫、你们的杰伊、你们的强尼、你们的史蒂夫·艾伦、你们的杰克·帕尔和你们的迪克·卡维特的敬意一路飙升——我本来就喜欢他们。我从来没有过像——我本来就喜欢他们，但我的敬意直冲云霄，我想，哦，
my God, this is a really hard job and it's not anything like you think it is. Are you still loving doing it? Oh, absolutely. I mean, I want the audience back, but it wasn't literally wasn't on the bucket list to do this gig. And when I was offered, I went, God, it's the only fucking promotion I could think of is to take that job and no one's ever going to offer it to me again. I'll give it a shot.
天哪，这是一份非常艰难的工作，它和你想象的完全不一样。你现在还热爱这份工作吗？哦，绝对的。我是说，我想要观众回来，但做这个差事绝对不在我的必做清单上。当有人向我提供这个机会时，我想，天哪，这是我能想到的唯一他妈的升职机会，那就是接下这份工作，而且再也不会有人把它让给我了。我得试一试。
Right. Right. I'll give it a shot. Thinking of it that morning and doing it that night and finding out cause the audience makes the special sound with their mouths and you know that work and you get to pull another piece of Kleenex out of the box tomorrow. That's what I love about it. I've been doing it for a year now with none of that and my kids got to see the guy crump
对，对。我得试一试。那天早上构思它，那天晚上把它演出来，然后发现——因为观众会用他们的嘴发出那种特殊的声响，你知道那个作品成了，明天你就可以从盒子里再抽出一张面巾纸了。这就是我喜欢它的地方。我已经这样过了一年，却没有这一切，而我的孩子们看到了这个崩溃的家伙
for the first two weeks. I kind of like just imploded in front of the camera and then I went, okay, stop complaining. This is what it is. And then I found some real enjoyment in it. I found an action and ability to like take, take some risks that I couldn't with a live order. Yeah. Jason, Sue, cause you said you, you know, your daughter did your makeup and Jason's
在前两周，我在镜头前简直崩溃了，然后我说，好吧，别抱怨了，这就是现实。接着我在其中找到了一些真正的乐趣。我找到了一种行动力，能够去冒一些我在直播时不敢冒的险。对啊。杰森，苏，因为你们说过，你知道的，你女儿帮你化了妆，还有杰森的
daughters do his makeup every morning before he goes to the mall or whatever. And I think that that's nice too to have that connection. You know what I'm saying? We got to connect once a day. Yeah. Yeah. You're dying to get back to audiences then, right? Yeah.
女儿每天早上在他去商场或者其他地方之前给他化妆。我觉得这也是件好事，能有那种联系。你知道我的意思吗？我们每天得联系一次。对的。对的。你们很渴望回到观众面前吧？是的。
When do you think that'll happen? Probably the next two, three months, right? Somewhere between three months and three years from now because you keep on getting these different messages from people, but I think people are getting shots so quickly now. You know, when people can like show proof of vaccination and we can do like a, like they're like seven minute rapid tests coming down the pipe when we can do that. Right. And I can have 400 people that I don't want, I want to go back on that stage like I left
你们觉得那会是什么时候？大概接下来的两三个月吧？从现在算起，大概在三个月到三年之间吧，因为你一直从人们那里听到各种不同的消息，但我认为现在大家接种疫苗的速度太快了。你知道的，当人们能够出示疫苗接种证明，并且像那种七分钟出结果的快速检测普及的时候，我们就能做到那一点。对吧。而且我可以有400个人，我不想，我想回到那个我离开的舞台
that. Yeah. I bet that's June. I mean, now that Biden said May 1st, everyone's going to be, everyone's going to qualify. Yeah. That's June, right? Middle of June? Yeah.
上。是的。我敢说那是六月。我是说，既然拜登说了5月1日，每个人都会，每个人都符合条件了。是的。那是六月对吧？六月中旬？是的。
June, July, maybe after the 4th of July, something like that. Cause if Biden says we can all get together for small parties, you know, in 4th of July I think it's reasonable by mid-July cause we're off for those first two weeks. By mid-July we might be able to do that, but I don't, don't hold me to that cause I don't, I don't have any idea. Oh well. I don't know how else to hold it to. Yeah.
六月，七月，也许在独立日之后，诸如此类。因为如果拜登说我们都可以在独立日聚在一起举行小型派对，我认为七月中旬是合理的，因为我们前两周都在休息。到七月中旬我们也许就能做到这一点，但别，别拿这个来要求我，因为我不知道，完全没有头绪。哦，好吧。我不知道还能怎么抱希望。是的。
Me neither. You said it. It just comes down on you man a little bit. Yeah. Come back to you and ask what happened. So if it doesn't go the right way. Have you guys ever talked to Conan? Cause he talks a lot.
我也不知道。你说的对。这事儿确实有点压得人喘不过气来，老兄。是的。回头来问你发生了什么。所以如果事情进展不顺的话。你们跟柯南聊过吗？因为他很会说。
We talked to Conan. We cut him off the word. We cut a fucking. I want you to promise me you're not going to broadcast that. You have our word. You have our word. You are a very, very generous man with your time, your spirit, your stories, and your laughter.
我们跟柯南聊过。我们打断了他。我们他妈的打断了……我希望你答应我，你不会把那段播出去。我们答应你。我们答应你。你是一个非常非常慷慨的人，肯花时间，贡献你的精神、你的故事和你的笑声。
Stephen. Oh, Stephen. Thank you guys. Thank you so much. So funny. Thank you very, very much for doing this. Thank you, Stephen. This was so fun, you guys.
斯蒂芬。哦，斯蒂芬。谢谢你们。非常感谢。太搞笑了。非常非常感谢你们做这些。谢谢你，斯蒂芬。这太有趣了，伙计们。
This was worth the burn out. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
这就算精疲力竭也值了。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you for burning a couple of hours on a Saturday. I hope so. We appreciate it very much. Thank you for being such a nice guy. So fun.
谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢你们在周六消磨了几个小时。希望如此。我们非常感激。谢谢你这么好。太有趣了。
See you guys in the wrestling. All right. See you, buddy. Bye, Stephen. Thank you. Thanks, man. Thank you. Bye, buddy.
摔跤节目里见。好的。再见，老兄。再见，斯蒂芬。谢谢。谢谢，伙计。谢谢。再见，伙计。
So are we really leaving? We're really leaving. Yeah, yeah. We're really leaving. Okay. I just know what this one of those things were. You broke me with the Conan story. You fucking broke me in half.
所以我们真的要走了吗？我们真的要走了。对，对。我们真的要走了。好吧。我只是觉得这事儿有点……柯南的故事把我给整破防了。你他妈把我劈成两半了。
I never recovered. True story. I never recovered. True story. I never recovered. We cannot use that as what you're saying. How about this? If he ever talks about it, if he ever said anything about me, drop it adduce when we're
我再也没恢复过来。真实的故事。我再也没恢复过来。真实的故事。我再也没恢复过来。我们不能用你刚才说的那段。这样吧？如果他以后提起这事，如果他说了关于我的任何话，当我们滑雪时……
skiing. If he ever says anything like that, then all bets are off, obviously, but I don't know anything about that. Yeah. Because that never happened, according to you. The other one never happened either. What did he say anything about me? Because I know nothing about this.
如果他说了类似的话，那所有赌注都取消了，显然，但我对此一无所知。是的。因为根据你的说法，那根本没发生过。另一件事也没发生过。他说了关于我的什么吗？因为我对这事一无所知。
Listen, we're not allowed to say anything about anything. We're with an NDA with you. We're going to NDA with him. Yeah. Okay. So you're saying he said something. I can't say that he said anything. I don't even know.
听着，我们对任何事都不能发表任何言论。我们和你签了保密协议。我们和他也有保密协议。是的。好吧。所以你是说他说过什么。我不能说他说过什么。我甚至不知道。
I'm not even allowed to acknowledge the fact that he can talk. Okay. Good. And whatever you do, whatever you do, do not broadcast the fact that up close, Conan looks like one of those guys, they fish out of a bog in Ireland who was sacrificed in some Celtic ceremony like 3,000 years ago. And like you see him in the museum in Dublin and they look like a catcher's mitt up in Cooper's town that was used by like shoeless Joe Jackson when they forgot to oil for a hundred
我甚至不被允许承认他会说话这件事。好吧。很好。无论你做什么，无论你做什么，千万不要把这件事广播出去：近看柯南长得就像爱尔兰泥炭沼里捞出来的那种家伙，他在大约三千年前的某次凯尔特仪式上被献祭了。然后你在都柏林的博物馆里看到他们，他们看起来就像库珀斯敦的捕手手套，曾被无鞋乔·杰克逊用过，而他们有一百年没给它上过油了
years. You don't want us to say that. You don't want us to have you on record saying that. That is super important to that not happen. Of course. And we'll respect that. We'll respect that. Right.
你不想让我们说这个。你不想让我们把你的这段话记录在案。绝对不能让这件事发生，这超级重要。当然。我们会尊重的。我们会尊重的。对吧。
Right. Exactly. Because he still can bust a move in this town. I don't want to make any enemies. Of course. You're safe with us. We understand that. All right.
对。没错。因为他在这个圈子里依然吃得开。我不想树敌。当然。你在我们这很安全。我们懂的。好吧。
Goodbye. This is for real. Goodbye, Stephen. Thank you. Goodbye. Goodbye. All right. I'm going to get a conversation going.
再见。这是动真格的了。再见，斯蒂芬。谢谢。再见。再见。好吧。我要去挑起一个话题了。
Knows how to keep it going. Keep it going. Okay. So that was crazy to hear Colbert tell a story that feels like we heard a different side of. Yeah. Conan has a completely different. And the question is now who's who's the liar?
懂得如何继续聊下去。继续聊。好吧。所以听到科尔伯特讲一个我们听过不同版本的直觉故事，这太疯狂了。是的。柯南有一个完全不同的版本。问题是，现在谁是谁非？
You know. Right. And I guess this is where it comes into what camp are you in? Are you in Colbert's camp now? Right. Or are you in Conan's camp? I'm going to say at first I believed Conan but you know now that Stephen was just on it maybe because it was just on he was extremely persuasive in his specific and very specific
你知道的。没错。我想这就落到了你站在哪一边的问题上。你现在是站在科尔伯特这边？对吧。还是站在柯南这边？我要说的是，起工时我信了柯南，但你知道，既然斯蒂芬刚刚谈到这事，也许因为他刚讲过，他在自己的具体经历上极具说服力，而且非常具体
right on the story seemed a lot more specific than Conan. He actually implied or even said that the excrement was safety cone orange. Yeah. Right. Obviously again as Colbert pointed out in show business you have to pick a side and you can never deviate from it. But I would say that knowing Conan and you know historically I've known Conan for whatever 20 years he's such a fucking liar so it's hard not to just immediately assume that he
直白，这个故事听起来比柯南的要具体得多。他甚至暗示或者明说了那些排泄物是安全锥橙色的。是的。没错。显然，正如科尔伯特所指出的，在演艺圈里你必须选边站，而且绝不能背离。但我想说的是，了解柯南，你知道从历史上看我认识柯南差不多20年了，他是个彻头彻尾的超级大骗子，所以很难不立刻断定他
because he is such a such an untruthful fucking person through and through. I mean when you run into him he opens with a lie. I don't know. Do you trust the fucking liar or do you trust the guy with the I guess I'm going to go Colbert. Yeah. Yeah. I'm team Colbert. Let's just do that.
因为他是个彻头彻尾、里里外外都不诚实的混蛋。我的意思是，你碰到他时，他一开口就是谎话。我不知道。你是该相信这个大话精，还是相信那个……我想我还是选科尔伯特吧。是的。是的。我是科尔伯特战队的。我们就这么定吧。
Let's just land there for now. Yeah. All right. Yeah. I think we're going to have to sustain the energy to do a daily talk show where you have to be you know interested every single day and write all of that stuff and it's just I know he's such a unique town. I don't really know him.
我们暂时就这么落脚吧。好吧。是的。我想我们要维持那种精力去做一个日常脱口秀节目，你必须每天都保持对事物感兴趣，还要写所有的段子，这真的……我知道他是个如此独特小镇里的人物。我其实不了解他。
I know him from through the business tree through like award shows and stuff we'd always end up getting kind of corralled into the same area for a number of years. It's just a quick wit. I think it's background holding as a prize. That's what they call it. That's what the B.H. was for and and then they would but we and he was always he and his wife were always so delightful and sweet and funny and cool and normal and and then of course as a performer he's just hilarious funny.
我通过商业圈认识他，比如通过颁奖典礼之类的活动，多年来我们总会被聚拢到同一个区域。他反应极其敏捷。我认为这跟他的背景有关。这就是所谓的“B.H.”代表的含义，然后他们会……我们，他和他的妻子总是那么令人愉快、甜美、有趣、酷炫且正常，当然，作为表演者，他简直滑稽又搞笑。
Yeah. Here's here's the thing Conan is such a liar that last year he tried to convince me honestly he with a straight face he's tried to convince me that he grew up in mum bye. Bye. Bye. Smart. Yes. Smart.
是的。事情是这样的，柯南是个大骗子，去年他试图说服我，真的，他面不改色地试图说服我，说他是在孟买长大的。拜。拜。拜。聪明。是的。聪明。
Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart.
是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。
是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的. 聪明。是的。聪明。
Yes. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。聪明。这个单集还没有评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。